liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
uns aus einem sehr ernsten Anlass heute
zu einer aktuellen Stunde verabredet die
nicht nur dieses Parlament und die
Abgeordneten im Deutschen Bundestag
betrifft sondern viele Millionen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in diesem Land
ist noch mal deutlich geworden mit dem
Zugriff der Reichsbürger was eigentlich
in diesem Land an Rechten Netzwerken
existiert welche hohe Bereitschaft an
Wald angeht wie weit es in die Teile der
Gesellschaft verstrickt ist und wie
knapp wir den Zugriff zuvorgekommen sind
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hier haben Menschen
vorbereitet im Deutschen Bundestag ein
Putsch durchzuführen sie haben versucht
Waffen einzuschmuggeln sie haben Zugriff
auf Waffen es geht um Hunderttausende
von Euro es gibt Meldung darüber dass
diese Ermittlungen noch andauern wir
sehen die Spitze eines Eisbergs und wir
müssen sagen dieser Rechtsstaat erst wer
hat er lässt sich von Nazis alten und
neuen und auch den Milieus der AFD und
der reichsbürgerinnen nicht auf der Nase
herum tanzen meine Damen und Herren
wir blicken in einen Abgrund an
Gewaltbereitschaft wir sehen eine enorme
Vorbereitungshandlung und wir sind da
den Ermittlungsbehörden in Polizistinnen
und Polizisten den Ermittlern dankbar
dafür dass sie so beherzt zugegriffen
haben wir sind aber auch worüber sehr
beruhigt das ist zu keinem Toten und
Verletzten gekommen ist denn wir haben
bei Reichsbürger Ratingen gesehen dass
Polizisten ermordet worden sind von
diesen reichsbürgern der das verharmlost
wer hier behauptet ist sind Spinner der
macht sich zum Teil des Problems der ist
die Ursache des Problems meine Damen und
Herren er muss eine klare Abgrenzung her
nichts mit dem
Herr Baumann dass sie hier reinrufen
ihre afd-kollegen gehört zu den
Festgenommenen schämen sie sich sie sind
Teil des Problems sie sind keine der
Demokratie sie versuchen das Problem
herunter zu reden sie verursachen diese
Meldung in diesem Bundestag in dieser
Republik Hass und Hetze trägt einen
Namen es ist die AFD meine Damen und
Herren
unmöglich schämen sie sich ein Grund es
sind ihre Belichtungen es sind ihre
Bediensteten die Sicherheitsüberprüfung
unterlaufen sie sind Teil des Problems
unfassbar halten sie inne
Sie verreden diese Razzia hören Sie mit
autoschiene auf der hat irgendwas gesagt
unmöglich meine Damen und Herren liebe
Mitbürgerinnen Mitbürger dort sitzen die
Verharmloser rechtsradikalen Terrors
wer glaubt dass das ein Rollator Kutsch
ist der darf nie vergessen dass es ihre
rechten Idole wie Paul von Hindenburg
mit 77 Jahren waren als er ins Amt kam
der diese Republik die erste
demokratische Republik zugrunde
gerichtet hat sie sind das Problem
und der Golden keine Verfassungsfeinde
in den Reihen deutscher
Sicherheitsbehörden diese
Verfassungsfeinde sind zu entfernen alle
Reichsbürger sind zu entwaffnen und
dafür werden wir auch das Waffenrecht
verschärfen das Disziplinarrecht anpass
das Beamtenrecht ist gibt keine Toleranz
für die Feinde der Republik Damen und
Herren
und wir sind am Anfang es steht jede
Abgrenzung es fehlt jede vorurteilung
von der rechten Ecke und darum liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kann man es
nicht hoch genug einschätzen dass wir
vor Jahren schon dazu übergegangen sind
mehr Bedienstete zum Verfassungsschutz
zu der agieren jeder Beamte der dort
arbeitet ist ein Beitrag dazu dass wir
diese rechten Netzwerke noch genauer
aufklären können und mit jedem Beamten
wissen wir mehr von den Netzwerken die
sich hier zusammen tun wir reden über
hunderte von Waffen wir reden über
hunderte von Objekten die durchsucht
wird wir reden davon dass es ein
militärischen Arm gibt das ist alles
kein Witz sondern ein ernstes Problem
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es ist gut dass wir ein
demokratiefördergesetz auf den Weg
bringen weil dazu gehört auch Prävention
es gibt auch hier kein
Verhandlungsspielraum man tritt entweder
für die freiheitlich demokratische
Grundordnung ein oder ist dagegen da
gibt es nichts dazwischen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und diejenigen
von uns die in den Sondersitzungen dabei
waren der Gremien oft geheimtagend ob es
möglicherweise auch vertraulich und
Verschlußsachen waren es ist schon
auffällig es ist schon sehr aufwendig
welche Fragestellung da aus der ganz
rechten Ecke kommt nicht nur der
Verharmlosung sondern der Versuche der
Ablenkung deswegen hier werden wir
hinschauen und es ist nicht hinnehmbar
dass Kollegen aus dem Bundestag daran
widwirkend ist im Zweifel lassen die
eine Frage ist dann doch zu beantworten
kriegen sie die Radikalisierung
eigentlich nicht mit ist das reiner
Zufall dass sich der Menschen so
radikalisieren wer denn das gemeldet und
deswegen werden wir an der Stelle auch
überprüfen wenn Polizisten Polizisten
angesprochen worden sind es ist richtig
dass das einzelne angezeigt worden aber
ein Polizist aus den Sicherheitsbehörden
ist einer zu viel denn es gibt so viele
Tausende von Bediensteten die jeden Tag
jeden Tag sich mit ihrer Gesundheit
dafür einsetzen unsere freiheitliche
demokratische Grundordnung zu
verteidigen und das ist die erdrückende
Mehrheit in dem Land wir sind mehr und
wir lassen es uns nicht bieten
Sebastian Hartmann hat hier die aktuelle
Stunde eröffnet einer der Anführer der
Gruppe soll Heinrich der 13 Reuss
gewesen sein er wohnt in Hessen und so
verwundert ist auch nicht dass hier der
Innenminister Hessens gleich sprechen
wird Peter Beute sehen Sie hier schon
auf der bundesratsbank sitzen er wird
sich hier auch gleich zu Wort melden
Heinrich der 13 Prinz Royce wollte
Staatsoberhaupt werden wenn denn dieser
Umbruch gelingen würde wenn er denn
geklappt hätte und deswegen ist das
natürlich auch für Hessen hier ein
besonders wichtiges Thema den man sich
annehmen möchte
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich danke Ihnen dass
ich als hessischer Innenminister heute
eine Länder Sicht bei der konsequenten
Bekämpfung gegen Reichsbürger und
Rechtsextremisten einbringen kann Bund
und vor allem auch Länder führen den
Kampf gegen Staatsfeinde und
Rechtsextremisten seit vielen Jahren mit
aller Konsequenz und mit allen ihnen zur
Verfügung stehenden Mitteln wir werden
und wir dürfen in diesem Kampf für
unseren demokratischen Rechtsstaat nicht
nachlassen meine Damen und Herren
es waren Hinweise und Ermittlungen aus
den Ländern welche die Umsturzpläne von
reichsbürgern im gesamten Bundesgebiet
aufdecken und diesen Schlag gegen die
Szene ermöglichen Verfassungsschutz
Polizei und Justiz haben diesen Erfolg
ermöglicht dafür können wir dankbar sein
von Teilen der Reichsbürger meine Damen
und Herren geht eine ernste Gefahr für
unsere Demokratie und ihre
Repräsentanten aus sie sehen in der
Bundesrepublik keinen souveränen statt
sie zweifeln sogar an seiner Existenz
die nun zerschlagene Gruppierung hatte
konkrete Pläne die ohne Gewaltanwendung
nicht umsetzbar gewesen wären das ist
diese Netzwerk letztlich nicht gelungen
wäre unsere freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung abzuschaffen mag als
gesichert gelten sicher ist aber auch
meine Damen und Herren dass diese
Menschen bewaffnet waren taktisch
geschult und Gewalt als legitimes Mittel
erachtet
auf dem Weg ihres Scheiterns hätten sie
gleich wohl schweren Schaden für unsere
Demokratie anrichten können wenn zum
Beispiel auch Menschen ums Leben oder zu
Schaden gekommen werden der Fall hat
deutlich gezeigt Reichsbürger mit ihren
Ideologien und ihrer waffenaffinität
dürfen von niemandem verharmlost werden
die Träume von exil-regierungen
Königreichen und in den Raum geworfenen
verschwörungsmythen klingen für manchen
noch immer nach Spinnerei im Internet
und bei ganz realen Treffen befördern
sie aber die Radikalisierung einzelner
oder wie festgestellt sogar einer großen
Gruppe von Staatsfeinden ich bin allen
Sicherheitsbehörden in unserem Land und
ihren mitarbeiten dank Mitarbeitern
dankbar die ihre Erkenntnisse
zielgerichtet ausgetauscht und gemeinsam
ein Gesamtbild des mutmaßlichen
Netzwerks herausgearbeitet haben
die schnelle Weitergabe und der ständige
Austausch von Informationen
untereinander haben in unserem föderalen
System funktioniert und die Rädchen
ineinander gegriffen diesen Austausch
benötigen wir auch in Zukunft um solche
Netzwerke erfolgreich auszuleben dieser
Austausch hat auch unterstrichen dass
die Sicherheitsbehörden aus der
selbstkritischen Analyse nach den
furchtbaren Norden des NSU ihre Lehren
gezogen haben und diese auch beherzigen
alle haben gemeinsam und konsequent an
einem Schrank gezogen und gezeigt dass
unser Staat und unsere Demokratie
wehrhaft sind und unsere freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung beschützt
wird
meine Damen und Herren unsere Behörden
können allerdings nur so gut schützen
wie wir als Gesetzgeber ist ihnen
letztlich ermöglichen
Waffen Waffen haben in den Händen von
Extremisten und reichsbürgern nichts
verloren meine Damen und Herren
nach wie vor ist es eine der wichtigsten
Aufgaben der Sicherheitsbehörden
Staatsfeinde konsequent ihre Waffen zu
entziehen seit 2019 bis mitte diesen
Jahres konnten wir allein in Hessen 100
Extremisten die Waffenerlaubnis
entziehen diese einzelnen Erfolge sind
jedoch stets mit sehr aufwendigen
Verfahren verbunden die wir längst durch
eine Änderung des Waffenrechts hätten
beschleunigen müssen wir uns wie von uns
seit Jahren gefordert das Waffenrecht
müsste dem einfachen Prinzip folgen wer
dem Verfassungsschutz als Extremist
bekannt ist darf keine Waffenerlaubnis
und keine legalen Waffen besitzen Punkt
ich teile ausdrücklich die Ankündigung
der bundesinnenministerin
Extremisten entwaffnen zu wollen
bis heute hat sich außer der kraftvollen
Ankündigung aber noch nicht Zählbares
getan ganz im Gegenteil der
Koalitionspartner FDP hat erst heute die
dringend notwendige Erinnerung unseres
Waffenrechts direkt wieder einkassieren
wollen und das mit dem in der Sache
völlig absurden Argument Extremisten
könnten sich ja dennoch illegal Waffen
besorgen dies gilt gelte ist zu
unterbinden meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ist es nicht möglich dass wir
uns bei der Frage keine Waffen in den
Händen von Extremisten auf eine logische
Reihenfolge einigen und am Anfang
beginnen
ist es nicht nachvollziehbar dass wir
zuerst den legalwaffenbesitz Versuchen
zu unterbinden
wer will nicht den Schwarzmarkt
austrocknen und illegale Waffen aus dem
Verkehr ziehen aber diese Ziele zu
erreichen ist vorsichtig gesagt noch ein
bisschen aufwendiger als die logisch
zwingende Regelversorgung für
Extremisten
wenn es Frau Ministerin juristisch nur
mit einer
tatbestandsangleichung und Waffenrecht
gehen sollte um das Prinzip zu erreichen
dann müssen wir das aber schnell
umsetzen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
die Uneinigkeit in der Ampelkoalition
blockiert das konsequente Vorgehen hier
für das Prinzip
im Bereich der Sicherheitsbehörden im
Waffenrecht das meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ist am Ende für die
Sicherheit in unserem Land weder
förderlich noch akzeptabel
der Schlag
unserer Sicherheitsbehörden in der
vergangenen Woche war gleich wohl ein
wichtiges Ausrufezeichen einer ein
unserer wehrhaften Demokratie vielen
Dank
die nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Dr
Irene mihalic für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und Irene hallesch ist erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin war
aber vor ihrer Zeit als Politikerin
selber auch Polizisten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen wir reden
hier über den größten Anti
terror-einsatz in der deutschen
Geschichte ein Einsatz im Milieu von
reichsbürgern und rechtsextremen und
unser aller Dank gilt den
Sicherheitsbehörden in Bund und Ländern
für diesen wirklich sehr guten guten gut
vorbereiteten und vor allen Dingen
erfolgreichen Einsatz meine dam
Reichsbürger sind eine Gefahr für unsere
Gesellschaft sie sind im mehrfachen
Wortsinne Feinde der Verfassung sie
verfolgen eine durch und durch
staatsfeindliche Ideologie die im Kern
antisemitisch revisionistisch und auch
anti-amerikanisch ist hinter der
bizarrenidee Deutschland sei nicht
souverän steckt die krude Vorstellung
dass Eliten in den USA das alles
irgendwie Steuern würden und wenn man
diese Zwiebel weiterschält kommt man
schnell zur sogenannten jüdischen
Weltverschwörung und es mag vielleicht
verrückt klingen wenn
qn und Anhänger vom deep state Phasen
und sich selbst in eine Allianz der
guten sehen doch was diese Erzählungen
so wahnsinnig bedrohlich macht meine
Damen und Herren ist ihre
Anschlussfähigkeit bis weit in die Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft und deshalb ist es
gefährlich wenn Reichsbürger und
rechtsextreme auf corona-protesten
Zustimmung finden wenn Menschen sich
nicht daran stören wenn Reichsbürger
Flaggen in Nachbargärten WE und
Verschwörungsideologien wenn da so
gesagt wird ah ja doch da konnte schon
irgendwie was dran sein nein meine Damen
und Herren hier braucht es aktiven
Widerspruch und hier müssen Demokraten
und Demokraten entschlossen
zusammenstehen
meine Fraktion hat vor der Gefahr die
von reichsbürgern ausgeht schon seit
Jahren gewarnt und an der Spitze der
Verharmloser damals stand Hans-Georg
Maaßen als er noch das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz leitete und seine
Einschätzung hat die Arbeit der
Sicherheitsbehörden unter
unionsgeführten Innenministerien viel zu
lange geprägt
die Reichsbürger wurden als harmlose
Spinne abgetan aber eben nicht als das
erkannt was sie eigentlich sind eine
verfassungsfeindliche und terroristische
Gefahr für die Sicherheit unseres Landes
und ist es gut dass unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden inzwischen ein
wirklich sehr scharfen Blick darauf
haben und diese schlimmen Anschlagspläne
vereitelt werden können
aber das
nun dran ist so Stimmen laut werden die
von verwirrten Rentnern und einer
hysterischen Berichterstattung sprechen
ist hochgradig besorgniserregend denn es
geht doch nicht um die
Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit eines
geplanten Staatsstreichs es geht jedoch
vor allem um die Terrorgefahr die Leib
und Leben von Menschen bedroht und dazu
gehört es auch
glasklar zu benennen dass der
parlamentarische Arm dieser Bewegung auf
der rechten Seite dieses Hauses sitzt
nämlich in der AFD die ehemalige
afd-abgeordnete war ganz vorne bei dem
Planungen für diesen Staatsstreich mit
dabei und in ihrer Fraktion werden
Mitarbeiter beschäftigt ja dem
gewaltbereiten rechtsextrem Milieu zu
Hause sind ihre Partei ist der
Brandbeschleuniger genau dieser
Demokratie feindlichen Bewegungen auch
wenn sie sich noch so sehr bemühen dass
alles zu verharmlosen und zu
relativieren das nimmt ihnen keiner ab
und es ist die Aufgabe aller fünf
demokratischen Fraktionen hier im Hohen
Haus eine effektive Brandmauer zu den
Demokratie Feinden von rechts zu bilden
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union da ist es aus meiner Sicht nicht
nachvollziehbar dass sie bei den
Protesten der letzten Generation ganz
schnell dabei sind von einer klimaeraf
zu reden aber jetzt wo sie es mal mit
echten Terroristen zu tun haben
schweigen sie tagelang
sie sollten dringend sie sollten
dringend ihren Kompass neu kalibrieren
und damit aufhören Öl ins Feuer zu
gießen auch in anderen Debatten die wir
hier im Haus führen werden Sie Teil der
Brandmauer meine Damen und Herren denn
wir brauchen sie ja und das rufe ich
hier nicht zum ersten Mal zu wir
brauchen Sie wenn der Kampf gegen die
Feinde der Demokratie erfolgreich sein
soll dazu müssen wir uns leider erneut
wieder mit radikalisierten Kräften auch
in Sicherheitsbehörden beschäftigen denn
es gab gezielte Rekrutierungsversuche
bei der Polizei und in der Bundeswehr
sondern und manche waren auch
erfolgreich auch in der Prävention gibt
es viel zu tun und deshalb ist es gut
dass das Kabinett heute das Demokratie
fördergesetz auf den Weg gebracht hat
gerade in diesen Zeiten sind wichtig und
ein Meilenstein meine Damen und Herren
und auch und auch für die Arbeit von
Polizei und Nachrichtendiensten müssen
wir Lehren ziehen und ich bin froh dass
wir mittlerweile eine Bundesregierung
haben die auf der Höhe all diese
Herausforderungen angekommen ist aber
meine Damen und Herren von der Union es
wäre noch besser zu wissen wenn wir in
solchen Fragen auch auf eine
demokratische
Opposition zählen können ganz herzlichen
Dank
war das für Bündnis 90 die Gründe im
Bundestag die afd-fraktion wurde hier ja
schon sehr deutlich angesprochen für die
afd-fraktion spricht nun ihr in
politische Sprecher Gottfried kurio
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsidenten meine Damen und
Herren Leute die glauben die staatliche
Ordnung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
bestünde nicht zu Recht irren sich wenn
solche Personen ihrem Irrglauben
Gewalttaten folgen lassen wollen handelt
es sich um Kriminelle Staatsfeinde und
wo ist dem Staat gelingt solche Leute
rechtzeitig zu enttaren zu entwaffnen
festzusetzen dann zeigt sich ein Stück
weit das funktionierendes Rechtsstaats
und vor allem seiner Sicherheitsbehörden
das gilt auch dann wenn man wieder
Ex-Innenminister Chile in der Gruppe
Zitat keine reale Bedrohung erkennen
kann und sie schlicht für Zitat skurrile
Spinner hält das gilt auch dann wenn
solche Leute in ihren Fähigkeiten
Lichtjahre entfernt waren von einer
Umsetzung verglichen mit dem Türkei
Putsch 2016 mit tausenden Soldaten
kampflugzeugen kann sein ein selbst dann
noch gescheiterter Patch insofern ist es
gut dass die personelle Basis der
festgesetzten hier nur gut zwei Dutzend
Leute umfasst im Zusammenhang mit einer
zweistelligen Zahl von Feuerwaffen gut
dass es nicht schlimmer gekommen ist und
neben etwa beabsichtigten Straf- und
Gewalttaten jedenfalls keine Gefahr für
die verfassungsmäßige Ordnung
Deutschlands Bestand vielleicht hielt
man ja selbst die Leute nicht für so
gefährlich dass man die
festsetzungsaktion quasi vorgeladenen
Gästen der Medien glaubte durchführen zu
können mit Namen Adressen und Zeitpunkt
selbst bei den kaufname des Risikos das
Beschuldigte Wind bekommen eine linken
Abgeordnete kritisiert so eine Festnahme
dürfen nicht zu einer Show geraten ein
Bekannter Journalist sieht in einer
derart vorab bereit gestreuten Aktion
eine pr-operation der generell
Bundesanwalt Bart doch wenigstens nicht
vor 7:30 Uhr zu berichten und nicht zu
gefährden usw auch nicht wie sonst
üblich mitten in der Nacht bestellte
Fernsehkameras sollten gute Bilder
einfangen das einzige was in diesem
fake-staatsstreich an diesem die
Zeitungen geschrieben Operetten
professionell war war die properation
des Innenministeriums wenn das nennt sie
Feser nicht ins hessische Parlament
trägt ja was denn dann meine Damen und
Herren aber gut dass die Gruppe
hochgenommen wurde
allem Drusen Vorstellungen auch konkrete
Handlungspläne auftauchen sollten man
möchte keine Waffe bei denen sehen auch
nicht die 19 Faustwaffen 25 Langwaffen
und elf Armbrüste auch keine
Finanzmittel nicht die 190.000 Euro die
Edelmetalle aber um auch
entspannungssignale zu geben nein die
Demokratie selbst muss er nicht
erzittern wenn König Heinrich der
fragwürdige beim Kaffeekränzchen auf
Schloss Waidmannsheil seine Paladine mit
den Ämtern und Würden seines
fantasiereichs belehnt und danach an
seine Rentner Combo die Schwerter und
Armbrüste austeilt elf Armbrüste stand
im Land womöglich eine konzertierte
Welle von Wilhelm tellaufführungen bevor
nur gut dass die rund 20.000
Reichsbürger mit 2000 gewaltbereiten
immerhin nicht dieselbe zahlenstärke
haben wie die Linksextremisten mit
35.000 gut 10000 gewaltbereit oder die
gute 28.000 Islamisten gut dass der GBA
neben den 130 is touristischen Verfahren
im ersten Halbjahr
22.09 im Rechtsextremismus führen muss
auch wenn jedes eins zu viel ist ein
ideologiefreierer Rundumblick klärt da
über die Proportionen auf gut nachs nach
dem messermord in Illerkirchberg die
Menschen immerhin keiner Angst davor
haben dass ihre Tochter auf dem Schulweg
von einem Reichsbürger erstochen wird
gut
weil Bundesanwaltschaft Montag
Bericht dieser Tage oft kolportierten
Angriff auf den Bundestag gerade nicht
für gegeben sah gut dass niemand wegen
des ehemaligen Stadtrats der CDU Frank R
Punkt unter den 25 Festgenommenen diese
Partei dann pauschal kollektive Haftung
nimmt ein letztes ist auch trotz allem
beruhigend wenn durch die Fülle der
Krisen in letzter Zeit bei Bürgern
irgendeiner Art von Staatsverdrossenheit
um sich greifen sollte die Leute nicht
mehr verstehen können dass Deutschland
Kernkraft aus Ideologie abschaltet
leichtfertig seine Energieversorgung
zerstört sich aufregen über die Politik
der Inflation der unbezahlbaren
Energiepreise der permanenten
Milliardenschulden sich aufregen über
die blutart von Iller Kirchen ein
weiteres
Opfer in einer Kette von Morden und
Messer stechereien wenn die Bürger
verzweifelt sind dass wenn die
Zuwanderung groteske Ausmaße annimmt mit
explodierenden mieten und überforderten
Kommunen die Regierung immer noch
weitere Anreize
zum plantschancenleiberecht für
unberechtigte Tore Einwirkung wenn all
das die Menschen zur Verzweiflung bringt
so müssen Sie nicht am Start am
parlamentarischen System selbst zweifeln
so gibt es Abhilfe innerhalb des
parlamentarischen Systems mit der AFD da
ist die Existenz und Arbeitsfähigkeit
der AFD die beste Versicherung des
Parlamentarismus gegen politische
Bestrebungen die sich reichsbürgerhaft
außerhalb des demokratischen Systems
stellen die Umfragen sind die AFD weiter
am Aufwärtstrend bei 15 16 Prozent auch
nach der letzten Woche die AFD steht für
den parlamentarischen Weg und die Bürger
Vertrauen ja immer mehr umso besser für
die Demokratie umso besser für
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
Gottfried kurio war das für die
afd-fraktion und nächste Redner ist
Marco Buschmann der Bundesjustizminister
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Besucherinnen und Besucher wenn die
größte Sorge nach diesen Ereignissen
Herrn kurio den Umfragewerten seiner
partei-geld hat er gezeigt was geistes-
am 7 Dezember diesen Jahres hat einer
der größten Anti-Terror-Einsätze der
letzten Jahre stattgefunden
es waren es handelte sich um
Durchsuchungen und Festnahmen das fand
an über 130 Objekten statt es waren etwa
3000 Polizistinnen und Polizisten
eingebunden die Ermittlungsmaßnahmen
richteten sich gegen eine mutmaßliche
terroristische Vereinigung diese
terroristische Vereinigung hat nach
Überzeugung des Generalbundesanwalt die
dafür notwendigen arbeitsteiligen und
hierarchischen Strukturen aufgebaut und
diese mutmaßliche terroristische
Vereinigung verfolgte natürlich das Ziel
der Beseitigung der freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung und des
Staates des Grundgesetzes dabei gab es
Pläne auch zu bewaffneten Überfällen auf
Verfassungsorgane und natürlich gab es
auch Äußerungen das war ja die
Begründung dafür unter anderem dass wir
hier von einer mutmaßlichen
terroristischen Vereinigung ausgehen
können die setzt nämlich die
anknüpfungsstraftaten von Mord und
Totschlag voraus aus dass diese Leute
mindestens billigend in Kauf genommen
haben das im Falle von Widerstand durch
Polizeibeamte diese Polizeibeamten auch
getötet werden sollten und das sind die
Fakten die der Generalbundesanwalt
seinen Maßnahmen zugrunde gelegt hat die
ein Ermittlungsrichter geprüft hat die
ein Haftrichter geprüftet und die die
Grundlage jetzt auch eines fairen
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahrens sein werden
und wer diese Dinge abstreitet und ist
Lächerliche zieht hat einfach nicht
verstanden worum es hier geht meine sehr
geehrten Damen und
diese Einsatz hat gezeigt dass dieser
Staat nicht blind ist nicht auf dem
linken nicht auf dem rechten Auge dieser
Einsatz ist eine logistische großartige
Leistung gewesen deshalb möchte ich dem
Generalbundesanwalt seinen
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeitern an dieser
Stelle für die Leitung dieses Einsatzes
danken und diese Einsatz zeigt diese
Demokratie ist wehrhaft wir können stolz
auf unsere Sicherheitsbehörden sein
es ist ja im Zusammenhang mit diesem
Einsatz gerade wieder aber auch schon
vorher versucht worden ihn ins
Lächerliche zu ziehen wir haben das bei
Herrn Choreograf erlebt wir haben das
von Frau weitel erlebt die von einem
rollator-putsch sprach und von ihrem
Kollegen Herrn bistron der von dem
größten Machtmissbrauch in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik sprach ich
muss sagen das ist absurd und von frei
von jeder Sachkenntnis ich will Ihnen
mal berichten welcher Gefahr sich unsere
Polizistin und Polizisten aussetzen wenn
sie gegen radikalisierte Reichsbürger
Vorgehen die Zugang zu Waffen haben ich
will Ihnen die Geschichte von Dirk er
erzählen
die Geschichte von dirke der mit seinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines
Sondereinsatzkommandos an der Zahl 30
Leute zu einem Objekt ging dort hatten
wir es mit Wolfgang Petr zu tun an
radikalisierter Reichsbürger der Zugang
zu Waffen hatte das haben die Behörden
erkannt haben die Waffenerlaubnis
natürlich widerrufen die
Waffenbesitzkarte eingezogen und weil er
seine Waffen nicht aushändigte sind die
Polizisten des SEK nach Jürgen bündt
gefahren um Georg P zu entwaffnen was
übrigens zeigt dass das heute auch
möglich ist und als Dirk Ehe vor der Tür
stand
hat Wolfgang P das Feuer eröffnet elf
Schüsse hat der abgegeben hat der Arm
ist durchbohrt worden eine Kugel ist in
die Lunge eingedrungen und dieser
Polizist ist im Einsatz nicht nur
verletzt worden er ist wenige Stunden
später im Alter von 32 Jahren gestorben
das zeigt welche Gefahr von
radikalisierten reichsbürgern ausgeht
die Zugang zu Waffen haben meine Damen
und Herren und wer das ins Lächerliche
zieht
wer das ins Lächerliche zieht versucht
diese Gefahr klein zu reden er versucht
auch die Gefahr klein zu reden der sich
unsere Polizistinnen und Polizisten
aussetzen wenn sie in solche Einsätze
gehen und der zeigt ihn Wahrheit dass
ihnen Leib und Leben unserer
Polizistinnen und Polizisten egal sind
und dafür sollten Sie sich schämen
und deshalb will ich eines sagen wenn
die Zahl von 3000 Polizistinnen und
Polizisten ins Lächerliche gezogen
werden ich habe gerade davon gesprochen
dass dir und seine Kollegen mit einem
Sondereinsatzkommando von 30 Leuten sich
einem Objekt genährt haben wenn wir von
über 130 Objekten ausgehen und von 3000
Polizistinnen und Polizisten dann haben
wir im Durchschnitt etwa 20
Polizistinnen und Polizisten an der
Stelle und ich finde es richtig dass die
taktische Einsatzleitung darauf Wert
legt dass man sich auf solche
eskalierenden Situationen vorbereitet
dass man in der Lage ist die Situation
notfalls unter Kontrolle zu halten und
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen die unter
Feuer stehen auch zu schützen und zu
retten und das ist nicht lächerlich das
ist die Fürsorgepflicht des dienstern
für seine Beamten
es gibt einen Punkt den ich hier als
Bundesjustizminister allerdings auch
erwähnen will dass relativiert
allerdings nichts von der Gefährlichkeit
es ist natürlich so dass der
Generalbundesanwalt diese Maßnahmen und
die Informationen über diese Maßnahmen
eingestuft hat der Generalbundesanwalt
hat übrigens keine Pressearbeit gemacht
wenn Sie das hier behaupten weil sich
das in aller entsteht der mir persönlich
versichert und mein Ministerium hat dazu
auch keine Öffentlichkeitsarbeit gemacht
und ich will an dieser Stelle sagen wenn
Beamte eingestufte Informationen die Sie
auf dem Dienstweg erreichen an Unbefugte
weitergehen dann machen sie sich
strafbar nach Paragraph 353 bitte
Strafgesetzbuches und wenn sie solche
Anschuldigungen erheben dann müssen Sie
wissen was sie da tun wenn es dazu
gekommen sein sollte dann werden
deutsche Staatsanwaltschaften dagegen
vorgehen auch das gilt im Rechtsstaat
meine Damen und Herren das mindert aber
in keiner Weise die Gefährlichkeit und
die Bedeutung dieses Einsatzes
ich will auch noch einen Satz dazu sagen
die Kollegin mirlic hat es verhindern
alle eigentlich schon erklärt aber Herr
kurio hat es immer noch nicht verstanden
die Frage dass wir es hier mit einer
terroristischen Vereinigung zu tun haben
hängt nicht an der Frage ob diese Leute
in der Lage wären die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung zu beseitigen
senkt an der Frage dass sie sich
vereinbart haben dass sie eine
arbeitsteilige Organisation aufgebaut
haben und bereit waren die Verbrechen
von Mord und Totschlag zu begehen und
das war nach Überzeugung des
generalbundesanwaltes der Fall und
dagegen also das ins Lächerliche zu
ziehen ist wirklich Protest und ich sage
an dieser Stelle natürlich wäre dieser
Kutsch nicht erfolgreich gewesen weil
die Mehrheit in unserem Lande hinter dem
Grundgesetz steht weil alle Demokratien
und Demokraten sich eins geschworen
haben das rechte Autoritarismus nie
wieder in diesem Land stärker sein wird
als Freiheit und Demokratie das hat er
genau
lustig macht sollte sich ganz
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann hat
hier noch einmal den Einsatz eingeordnet
und auch die Zahl der Einsatzkräfte über
die ja auch schon diskutiert wurde
Martina Renner spricht nun für die
Linksfraktion Sprecherin für
Antifaschismus sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
ich möchte auf zwei Punkte in der
Debatte der letzten Tage auch heute
morgen im Innenausschuss eingehen die
ich für folgenschwere Fehlannahmen halt
die erste irrige Annahme ist dass wir es
hier mit einer ideologisch die fußen
Szene zu tun hätten manche reden gar von
einem
salatbar-extremismus und in der Tat der
Geheimdienst behauptet nur etwa fünf
Prozent der sogenannten Reichsbürger
seinen rechtsextreme
der Rest sei irgendwie nicht zuzuordnen
oder es handelt es sich um
deren Wortschöpfung Vertreter
Verfassungsschutz relevanter
Delegitimierung des Staates
aber ist es wirklich so schwer zu
verstehen wer diese Leute sind was sie
wollen und warum sie gefährlich sind
diese Leute verbreiten mitunter auch als
Abgeordnete der AFD Rassismus gegen
geflüchtete
sie verbreiten antisemitische
Verschwörungstheorien über finstere
Mächte die die Welt aus dem geheimen
heraus lenken würden sie planen
Säuberungen und Entführungen politischer
Gegnerinnen
sie halten den Staat für schwach weil er
nicht hart genug durchgreift und sie
wollen eine autoritäre Diktatur
nennen wir die Dinge doch einfach mal
beim Namen wir haben es mit bewaffneten
Rechten zu tun die eine Gefahr für viele
Menschen und für die Demokratie sind
und auch der Umstand das hier ganz
unterschiedliche zum Teil Bruder
ideologische Aspekte zusammenkommen
widerspricht nicht dieser klaren
Einordnung
faschistische Ideologie zeichnete schon
immer aus dass sie in der Lage war
desperate irrationale oder gar
esoterische Elemente einzubinden
wenn wir dieses Problem dieses Phänomen
aber nicht begreifen dann werden wir es
auch nicht richtig bekämpfen können und
ich glaube wenn wir schon früher klar
gesprochen hätte über die rechte
reichsbürgerszene dann hätten wir auch
konsequenter entwaffnet das ist meine
feste Überzeugung
zweite nicht weniger Folgen schwere
Fehlannahme liegt der großen
Verwunderung zugrunde die ich jetzt die
letzten Tage immer wieder lesen und
hören musste die die Zusammensetzung
dieses Netzwerkes hervorruft eine
Richterin Polizisten Soldaten Ärzte es
sei erschüttert und vor allem neu das
bürgerliche Kreise ja die Mitte der
Gesellschaft Teil von Rechten
Verschwörung sein dieses Erstaunen ist
gefährlich aus ihm spricht das
Unvermögen sich Rechte anders als
extremistische Proleten vorzustellen es
zeugt vom Wunsch Rassismus und
Antisemitismus nur dort zu verorten wo
es möglichst wenig mit einem selbst zu
tun hat und es offenbart ein
gefährliches Unwissen zur Geschichte der
extremen Rechte
erinnern wir uns an das rechte
nordkreuznetzwerk es waren Soldaten
Polizisten Anwälte die Waffen horteten
und Gegnerinnen ermorden wollten und wer
förderte eigentlich die Wehrsportgruppe
Hoffmann deren Mitglieder Shlomo Levin
und Frieder Pasch Getöteten und aus
deren Umfeld das Oktoberfest Attentat
verübt wurde das war ein Verleger und
Immobilienbesitzer ein Adeliger und ein
rüstungsfabrikant um nur einige zu
nennen wir können auch gerne weiter
zurückgehen in der deutschen Geschichte
und werden immer wieder sehen die
extreme Rechte war nie ein Phänomen der
extremistischen Ränder der
gesellschaftlichen Ränder es waren immer
die bürgerlichen Kreise die Stützen der
Gesellschaft von denen die rechte Gefahr
für die Demokratie ausgeht
die nicht abreißende Serie rechter
Netzwerke die sich mindestens seit 2015
auf den Weg machen einen rechten Putsch
vorzubereiten zeigen diese Gefahr diese
Gefahr ist brandaktuell
für die
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer hat
ich schon vorher gesagt sie möchte das
Waffenrecht verschärfen und nun spricht
sie im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren heute vor einer Woche
haben wir in als Demokratin Demokraten
in einen Abgrund geblickt 3000
Polizeikräfte aus Bund und Ländern
teilweise auch Spezialkommandos waren im
Einsatz um eine terroristische Bedrohung
unserer Demokratie abzuwehren dabei
wurden 25 Personen festgenommen das
zeigt wir handeln und unser Rechtsstaat
ist wehrhaft meine Damen und Herren
und ich will hinzufügen das war für alle
Beteiligten ein hochgefährlicher Einsatz
und es war ein hoch erfolgreicher
Einsatz deshalb möchte ich zu Beginn
meiner Rede noch mal all diesen
Polizeibeamtinnen und Beamten aus Bund
und Ländern die einen hervorragenden Job
gemacht haben hier ganz herzlich danken
für diesen Einsatz sie haben unsere
Demokratie letzte Woche verteidigt
23.000 sogenannte Reichsbürger zählt das
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz Tendenz
steigend diese Zahl ist erschreckend und
sie ist nur hart man hat schon darauf
hingewiesen die Spitze des Eisbergs denn
wir sehen seit geraumer Zeit immer
engere Verbindungen zwischen
rechtsextremen Gruppierungen Frau Renner
Verschwörungstheoretikern reichsbürgern
aber auch Querdenkern die jetzt während
der corona-zeit entstanden sind das
sollte man auch nicht unterschätzen an
dieser Stelle und viel zu lange auch das
will ich sehr deutlich sagen war dieses
Szene unterschätzt viel zu lange wurden
Reichsbürger als harmlose Spinner
abgetan und wir haben es ja heute von
Herrn kurio wieder gesehen wie sehr es
verharmlost wurde mit diesem lächerlich
machen von dieser hochgefährlichen Szene
die mit Waffengewalt agiert mein Kollege
Justizminister Herr Buschmann hat darauf
hingewiesen was Reichsbürger
tatsächlich 2016 in georgens Gemünd
angerichtet haben indem sie brutals
durch die Tür hinweg einen
Polizeibeamten brutal ermordet haben und
wer da noch diese Szene ins lächerlich
zieht wie heute hat nicht nur nicht
verstanden wo die Gefahren in diesem
Land sind sondern sie
verharmlosen sie in einer Art und Weise
die diesem Land extrem schadet und es
gefährdet meine Damen und Herren
mit dem Lächeln
Herr Baumann sie müssen sich schon
zurechnen lassen was ihre Redner heute
hier machen und die reichsbürgerszene
ich will mal einen Blick noch weiten sie
bedrohen Kommunalpolitikerinnen und
Kommunalpolitiker die im Ehrenamt vor
Ort sich für andere einsetzen
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeitern von
öffentlichen Ämtern Journalisten all
diese
Menschen die tätig sind für unsere
Gesellschaft die sich für unsere
demokratische Grundordnung einsetzen die
werden von reichsbürgerinnen
reichsbürgern bedroht und wir haben
allein 239 Gewalttaten im letzten Jahr
gehabt durch reichsbürgern sie stellen
sich hier hin und verhohnen das das ist
wirklich gefährlich eine solche
Auffassung im Deutschen Bundestag zu
hören
und gerade deshalb braucht es diese
klare Haltung aller demokratenen
Demokraten und deswegen muss Schluss
sein mit der Verharmlosung der
Reichsbürger in unserem Land meine Damen
und Herren
und genau deshalb will ich dass wir
Extremisten und reichsbürgern
entschlossen und konsequent die Waffen
ziehen da will ich mich auch auf das
beziehen was der hessische Innenminister
heute hier gesagt hat das ist in vielen
Fällen schon passiert durch die
Waffenbehörden der Länder wir müssen da
konsequent weitermachen aber wir
brauchen weiteren Druck deshalb müssen
wir das Waffenrecht aus meiner Sicht
auch weiter verschärfen vor allem für
einen engeren
Informationsaustausch auch zwischen den
Behörden zwischen den Waffenbehörden
zwischen den Sicherheitsbehörden das ist
wirklich wichtig und ich glaube daran
wird auch keiner einen Zweifel haben
dass das notwendig ist dass wir nicht
wollen dass Extremisten im Waffen
besitzt sind
und damit wir unsere Demokratie auch
weiter wehrhaft bleibt müssen wir sie
von innen heraus stärken und dazu gehört
es auch und der Kollege Beuth diese
Bemerkung will ich mir aber nicht
ersparen wenn sie so stark für den
waffenentzug sind dann sorgen Sie auch
dafür dass ihre Partei diese Meinung
übernimmt in der letzten
Legislaturperiode waren es nämlich
cdu/csu die verhindert haben das ist zu
Verfärbung im Waffenrecht im Deutschen
Bundestag kam also deswegen nicht nur
dann argumentieren wenn es gerade passt
sondern diese Linie auch konsequent
weiter verfolgen das haben sie in Hessen
getan aber hier im Bund muss es dann
auch folgen damit unsere Demokratie
wehrhaft bleibt müssen wir sie aber auch
von innen heraus stärken und dazu ist
Prävention wichtig Prävention von Anfang
an in Kindertagesstätten in Schulen es
ist eines der wichtigsten Mittel der
Bekämpfung von Extremismus in unserem
Land und deswegen müssen wir darauf auch
fokussieren und deshalb bin ich meiner
Kollegin Lisa Pause der
Familienministerin natürlich auch
dankbar dass wir heute gemeinsam das
Demokratie fördergesetz vorstellen
konnten um die Zivilgesellschaft hier zu
stärken meine Damen und Herren sie sehen
wir handeln auch im Bereich der
Prävention außerdem werden wir das
Disziplinarrecht verschärfen denn wir
lassen nicht zu dass der Rechtsstaat von
Extremisten von innen heraus sabotiert
wird und das schulden wir letztlich
allen Angehörigen der
Sicherheitsbehörden des öffentlichen
Dienstes und das ist die überwältigende
Mehrheit die sich auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes bewegt meine Damen und
Herren und diesen Schutz haben die
Bediensteten auch von uns verdient und
deshalb werden wir Verfassungsfeinde
schneller als bisher aus dem
öffentlichen Dienst entlassen und ein
schnelleres Verfahren dafür auflegen und
konsequentere Behandlung von
volksverhetzungsdelikten auch vorsehen
den Gesetzentwurf werden wir noch vor
Weihnachten vorliegen meine Damen und
Herren
ich habe es zu Beginn meiner Amtszeit
gesagt die größte Bedrohung für die
demokratische
Grundordnung kommt von rechts und damit
haben wir das letzte Woche gesehen dass
es so ist meine Damen und Herren und
dass der Rechtsstaat hier konsequent
handeln muss der Einsatz gegen die
reichsbürgerszene in der letzten Woche
hat gezeigt unser Rechtsstaat ist stark
erst wehrhaft wir werden dafür sorgen
dass es so bleibt wir verteidigen die
Demokratie gegen alle Feinde egal von
welcher Seite vielen Dank
wenn sie Feser war das die
bundesinnenministerin hat hier das
Demokratie fördergesetz angesprochen
dass uns doch beschäftigen wird
vielleicht wird auch
Bundesfamilienministerin dieser Pause
etwas dazu sagen da geht es darum dass
gegen Extremismus gerichtete Initiativen
langfristiger und nicht nur auf Projekte
Basis gefördert werden sollen das haben
die Ministerinnen heute vorgestellt
Andrea Lindholz jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die
Bundesrepublik hat vor einer Woche einen
der größten Anti terror-einsätze ihre
Geschichte erlebt und ich möchte daher
auch für die Unionsfraktion zunächst
einmal ganz herzlich allen
Einsatzkräften den Generalbundesanwalt
und den Beteiligten Sicherheitsbehörden
für ihre professionelle Arbeit den Dank
aussprechen es war ein komplexer und
gefährlicher Einsatz
in der waffenaffinen Szene der
Reichsbürger und es ist damit auch gut
und es ist auch ein Erfolg das
zahlreiche Beschuldigte in Haft genommen
werden konnten und auch niemand
ernsthaft zu Schaden gekommen ist auf
unseren Antrag hin liebe Frau mehrhalic
und gegen das Votum der Ampel hat die
Bundesregierung am Montag das Parlament
in zwei Sondersitzungen des Innen- und
Rechtsausschusses über den Verstand der
Ermittlungen informiert sie haben sich
dagegen ausgesprochen und wir haben
gesehen es war gut dass das Parlament
informiert worden ist
denn gerade auch die Auswertung der
Razzia die noch länger dauern wird hat
aber bereits am Montag folgendes
deutlich gemacht die reichsbürgergruppe
die die Existenz der Bundesrepublik
leugnet und die auch Umsturzpläne
verfolgte war gefährlich Mitglieder der
Gruppe besaßen Waffen sie konnten mit
ihnen umgehen und sie sind auch
gewaltbereit mindestens einmal hat man
sich zu einer Schießübung getroffen es
wäre daher falsch und es ist falsch
diese Gruppe als bloße spinnergruppe
abzutun aber es ist auch klar und das
ist auch gut so unsere Demokratie stand
auch nicht kurz vor einem Umsturz es ist
für mich unerträglich wenn von Seiten
der AFD versucht wird den Vorgang mit
Worten wie Rollator Putsch ins
Lächerliche zu ziehen und es ist
für mich unerträglich Herr Dr kurio man
kann das alles nachhören und den
Faktencheck machen dass sie auch hier
wieder heute mit ihrer Rede versucht
haben diesen ganzen Vorgang und die
Notwendigkeit zu relativieren sie müssen
sich schon die Frage gefallen lassen
warum ausgerechnet mehrere Mitglieder
der AFD
und Glied dieses Bundestages aus ihrer
Gruppe im engsten Führungskreis mit
vertreten war mit ihren
relativierungsversuchen
offenbaren sie eine schräge Sicht auf
unseren Rechtsstaat der
Generalbundesanwalt hat anhand konkreter
Fakten und nicht eben mal einfach so und
nicht ohne Grund vom Anfangsverdacht
einer Betätigung in einer Terroristen
terroristischen Vereinigung gesprochen
der geht davon aus und deswegen ist auch
sämtliche Relativierung deplatziert
das gilt im übrigen auch für die Linken
die von einer PR-Aktion sprechen das
geht im übrigen auch von das gilt im
übrigen auch liebe lieber von Notz für
für Otto Schilly der von einer skurrilen
spinnergruppe gesprochen hat
bzw rausgegriffen ist es genau das genau
solche Sätze relativieren den Einsatz
und hinterlassen bei dem ein oder
anderen in der Bevölkerung die Frage
zurück war das alles so notwendig und da
gehört auch zur Wahrheit dazu dass auch
die Pressearbeit in diesem Zusammenhang
hinterfragt werden muss es ist doch
nicht in Ordnung wenn die
Innenministerin sich hinstellt und sagt
sie habe angeblich erst einen Tag vorher
von dem Umstand gewusst es ist auch
nicht zielführend wenn der
Justizminister darstellt und sagt sein
Haus war es auch nicht wenn aber beim
Einsatz massenweise
vor Ort ist schneller da ist als manche
Einsatzkraft da ist was schief gelaufen
und der erwarte ich auch von ihnen dass
sie das Aufklären es geht hier um den
Geheimnisverrat es geht um den Verrat
von Dienstgeheimnissen und ich möchte
von Ihnen wissen wie Sie diese Vorgänge
aufklären und nicht nur sagen ich habe
nichts davon gewusst weil das kann nicht
sein
und nach den Ausschusssitzungen am
Montag im Innen und Rechtsausschuss ist
eines klar die Ermittlungserfolge
beruhen auch auf Maßnahmen der
Innenminister der Union ich will das
ganz klar sagen es war innenminister
Friedrich der 2012 das gemeinsame
Extremismus und terrorismusabwehrzentrum
von Bund und Ländern zu Bekämpfung von
Rechtsextremismus gegründet hat und das
war maßgeblich beteiligt am Erfolg
dieser Tage das hat auch die Sitzung
ergeben Thomas de Maizière der
Innenminister 2016 die
reichsbürgerbewegung aus gutem Grund die
Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz
beschlossen Horst Seehofer hat 2019
unter anderem die regelabfrage der
Waffenbehörden bei Verfassungsschutz mit
diesem Haus hier eingeführt damit legale
Waffen möglichst erst gar nicht in die
Hände von Extremisten gelangen und er
hat 2020 in zehn Bundesländern gegen
Reichsbürger durchgeführt und erstmals
eine Gruppierung verboten der Kampf
gegen Extremismus und gegen Reichsbürger
muss nachhaltig andauernd auf vielen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Ebenen gewährt machen sie mal den
Faktencheck schauen Sie sich mal
Pressearbeit von uns an wir sind an
dieser Kollegen glasklar gewesen Frau
Kollegin sie hätten zum Ende gekommen
sein müssen
damit komme ich zum Ende wir müssen
sehen
müssen was noch ange
zeigt dafür habe ich jetzt nicht mehr
genug Zeit vielen Dank
Andrea Lindholz die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
und die nächste Rednerin wurde schon
angesprochen Lisa Paus die
Bundesministerin für Familie Senioren
Frauen und Jugend
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin
hörte zuschauende zuhörende
es sind Soldaten Polizisten eine Ärztin
eine Richterin und sogar eine ehemalige
Abgeordnete des Deutschen Bundestages
die die Sicherheitsbehörden vor einer
Woche festgenommen haben bei der Razzia
gegen rechtsbürgerinnen es sind Menschen
die Verantwortung in unserem Rechtsstaat
tragen dennoch haben sie sich zu
Staatsfeinden erklärt und greifen die
Grundfesten unserer Demokratie an und
das ist schlichtweg schockierend
und es ist gut dass unser Rechtsstaat
darauf eine klare Antwort gibt denn
sogenannte Reichsbürger sind eben nicht
nur irgendwelche Spinner sie haben gute
Verbindungen in unsere Institutionen sie
können durch Insiderwissen Behörden
potenziell sogar lahmlegen sie haben
konkrete Umsturzpläne die auch über eine
Störung und dieses Hauses verwirklicht
werden sollten sogenannte Reichsbürger
sie sind Menschen die unseren Staat und
unsere Demokratie zerstören wollen
die auch bereit sind zu töten Herr
Busmann hat das noch mal sehr klar
dargelegt wie das 2016 gewesen ist in
georgsmünd dort haben sie es bewiesen
ein Polizist ist im Einsatz gegen einen
Reichsbürger getötet worden und deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden dass die
generalbundesstaatsanwaltschaft dass die
Polizei aus Bundesländern wachsam waren
und dass sie so konsequent gehandelt
haben
eine Werte Demokratie sie braucht
wachsame und kompetente
Sicherheitsbehörden wachsam nach außen
aber auch nach innen eine wehrhafte
Demokratie braucht engagierte
Polizistinnen wie die 3000 die letzte
Woche die Razzia in 11 Bundesländern
durchgeführt und zum Erfolg geführt
haben und für ihren Einsatz möchte ich
mich ausdrücklich und den allergröße
bedanken
eine Werte demokratie braucht aber auch
eine starke Zivilgesellschaft eine
Zivilgesellschaft die die Werte der
Demokratie der Vielfalt und des
Miteinanders liegt die trotz aller
unterschiedlichen Meinungen Kompromisse
findet die gemeinsame Projekte auf die
Beine stellt
dafür stellt mein Ministerium im
Bundesprogramm Demokratie leben allein
für das kommende Jahr 182 Millionen Euro
zur Verfügung
182 Millionen Euro für die Förderung
unserer Demokratie und die Gestaltung
von Vielfalt für
für die Prävention von Rechtsextremismus
Rassismus und Antisemitismus diese
Arbeit sie fördern wir auf kommunaler
auf Landes- und auch Bundesebene denn
Demokratieförderung ist dann besonders
erfolgreich wenn verschiedene
Institutionen und Organisationen sich
daran beteiligen wenn eben nicht nur die
Bürgermeister in und der Gemeinderat
sondern auch der Sportverein mitmacht
wenn die Kirche genauso wie die Polizei
wenn Unternehmen genauso wie der
Jugendclub dabei sind die weit mehr als
600 Initiativen die wir das
Bundesprogramm Demokratie leben fördern
gehen deshalb gezielt an die
unterschiedlichen Lebensorte auch die
Prävention in Haftanstalten und im
Internet sind wichtige Bereiche des
Bundesprogramms denn Demokratie sie kann
nicht von oben verordnet werden
demokratie braucht Menschen die sie in
den Institutionen
der repräsentativen Demokratie vertreten
demokratie braucht Menschen die sich
Initiativen Organisationen für ein
gemeinsames Miteinander einsetzen
diesen Menschen die unsere Demokratie
täglich mit Leben erfüllen Haupt oder
ehrenamtlich gilt ebenfalls mein Dank
wir wollen und werden diese engagierten
Menschen jetzt noch besser fördern denn
heute hat die Bundesregierung das
Demokratie fördergesetz im Kabinett
verabschiedet noch mal ganz herzlichen
Dank auch an meine Kolleginnen wenn Sie
dieses Gesetz bringt uns wirklich ein
sehr großen Schritt voran denn damit
haben wir zum ersten Mal den
gesetzlichen Auftrag für den Bund
geschaffen
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement für
Demokratie gegen Extremismus für
vielfaltgestaltung und für politische
Bildung in seiner Qualität zu sichern
und zu stärken ein solches Gesetz hat es
bislang in Deutschland nicht gegeben
meine Damen und Herren und damit machen
wir klar Demokratie Förderung sie ist
eine dauerhafte staatliche Aufgabe wir
stellen diese Förderung eine gesetzliche
und damit stabilere Grundlage damit
schaffen wir endlich Planungssicherheit
für die Initiativen dass Demokratie
fördergesetz liegt das Fundament für
eine längerfristige für eine
bedarfsorientierte und für eine
altersunabhängige Förderung von
zivilgesellschaftlichen Projekten
sind die Aufdeckung des terronetzwerks
zeigt beim reichsbürgermilieu handelt es
mitnichten sich nur um junge Erwachsene
die vielleicht auch Abwege geraten sind
sondern es handelt sich um Menschen die
voll im Leben stehen und die vorsätzlich
unsere Demokratie zerstören wollen die
wissen dass ihr Gerede von der
angeblichen Diktatur in der wir alle
leben sollen bei einigen Menschen
tatsächlich seine toxische Wirkung zeigt
und daher gilt es den Blick in der
Präventionsarbeit noch stärker zu weiten
alle Altersgruppen zu erreichen was
ändert sich durch das demokratiegesetz
konkret beispielsweise können wir jetzt
das Beratungsnetz für Opfer von
rechtsextremer oder rassistischer Gewalt
stärker ausbauen hier ist eine
längerfristige Förderung besonders
wichtig da die Begleitung von gerade
traumatisierten Opfern oft mehrere Jahre
dauert oder auch die Beratung der
mobilen die Arbeit der mobilen Beratung
können wir durch das Demokratie
fördergesetz weiterentwickeln
beispielsweise wurden im Land
Brandenburg 2000 zum Umgang mit
reichsbürgern in früheren Jahren
geschult und das erste Handbuch dazu war
ist auch von der entsprechenden Projekt
herausgegeben worden aus diesem
Fachwissen können wir jetzt ein
längerfristiges und breites
Unterstützungsangebot machen so wichtig
in dieser Zeit
sie sehen also
die Bundesregierung ist entschlossen die
Bundesregierung handelt gegen die
Demokratie Feinde aber eben auch für
diejenigen die die Demokratie mit ihrem
Engagement und ihrem Mut schützen und
sich für sie einsetzen und das ist die
übergroße Mehrheit in unserem Land und
deshalb werden die Feinde der Demokratie
auch niemals Erfolg haben herzlichen
Dank
die
Bundesministerin für Familien Senioren
Frauen und Jugend Elisa Paus war das und
damit die dritte Ministerin die hier
gesprochen hat Katrin Helling klar nun
für die FDP-Fraktion die
rechtspolitische Sprecherin sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
und Herren
ein Mann Ende 60 am Rande der
Gesellschaft erträgt eine alte
tweetjacke tippt auf telegram wird Texte
hält die BRD für eine GmbH ist als
notorischer Querulant in der ganzen
Nachbarschaft bekannt wird belächelt so
oder so ähnlich haben sich viele bisher
Reichsbürger vorgestellt
die Realität Richter Ärzte Polizisten
Lehrer ehemalige Soldaten und eine
afd-abgeordnete 400.000 Euro in bar Gold
und Silbermünzen 93 Waffen Ausrüstung
und Satellitentelefone konkrete Pläne zu
Putsch und Exekutionen zu Säuberungen
bei Kommunalpolitikern und zum Aufbau
einer neuen Regierung und
Verwaltungsstruktur Deutsches Reich ein
Geheimer Rat Heimatschutz Kompanien was
mich von vorgestern und vorvorgestern
klingt ist offenbar heute traurige
gefährliche Gegenwart dem
Generalbundesanwalt und allen
beteiligten Behörden und Beamten gilt
unser Dank für Ihr entschlossenes
Vorgehen
Durchsuchungsmaßnahmen in über 130
Objekten in elf Bundesländern 25
Festnahmen von Niedersachsen bis Perugia
in Italien 3.000 Polizisten waren
beteiligt das ist ein Erfolg den es zu
würdigen gilt
ganz offenkundig haben die
unterschiedlichen Akteure und Behörden
reibungs- und geräuschlos wie Zahnräder
ineinander gegriffen die Ermittlungen
laufen weiter und vermutlich ist das was
schon bekannt ist nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs was wir aber schon wissen eine
dreistellige Anzahl von Personen hat
sogenannte Verschwiegenheitserklärung
unterschrieben das ganze Ausmaß können
wir neu erahnen das muss uns zu denken
geben und uns zeigen wir müssen noch
wachsamer sein die festgenommene
afd-abgeordnete hat vor etwas mehr als
einem Jahr noch hier in diesem
Plenarsaal in diesen reingesessen sie
hat hier gesprochen sie war in der
afd-bundestagsfraktion offenbar tief
verwurzelt sie hat ja bis heute
parteiaufgaben und ist Nachrückerin auf
der Landesliste die AFD hatte sogar
mehrfach für einen Sitz im
Vertrauensgremium dass ich unter anderem
um die vertraulichen Wirtschaftspläne
der Nachrichtendienste des Bundes
kümmert vorgeschlagen
dass wir sie nicht gewählt haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Ermittlungen des Generalbundesanwalts
haben den Verdacht ergeben dass konkrete
Vorbereitungen getroffen worden sind um
hier im Deutschen Bundestag mit Waffen
Gewalt einen Machtwechsel zu erzwingen
Birgit meiser-winkelmann und ihre
Verbündeten wollten offenbar hier
beginnen die Demokratie zu beseitigen
aber nicht nur sie sondern auch weitere
Verdächtige haben eine Nähe zur
Alternative für Deutschland oder sind
Mitglied es geht ihnen allen darum
unsere Demokratie zu beseitigen und das
werden wir nicht zulassen meine Damen
und Herren unser Rechtsstaat wer haftet
auch unsere Demokratie ist Wert alle
Gewalt geht in unserem Staat vom Volk
aus nicht von radikalen macht Fantasten
sie zu blutigen Terror bereit sind
unsere Aufgabe wird es also sein noch
deutlicher zu machen wer sich unter dem
deckmännlichen einer vermeintlichen
Alternative für das Land eigentlich
versteckt
aufzuklären für unsere Demokratie und
unseren Rechtsstaat zu be begeistern in
die Breite der Gesellschaft hinein das
geltende Waffenrecht lässt eine
konsequente Entwaffnung von
reichsbürgern bereits zu ihr braucht es
das Personal bestehende Regelung
anzuwenden und auch den exekutiven
Willen die es tatsächlich zu tun es kann
nicht sein dass auf Bundesebene eine
weitere Verschärfung des Waffenrechts
vor allem deshalb den Weg in die
Diskussion findet weil in manchen
Bundesländern da in Bezug auf
Reichsbürger noch immer nicht
entschlossen genug vorgegangen wird
den Bundestag
den Bundestag und seine Liegenschaften
werden wir besser schützen müssen indem
wir einen genauen Blick auch auf die
ehemaligen Ausweise haben in die Hände
von Birgit meiser-winkelmann und
Ihresgleichen gehören solche Ausweise
jedenfalls nicht
und auch das Disziplinarrecht für Beamte
werden wir uns anschauen denn Beamte
stehen in einem besonderen
treue-verhältnis zum Staat wer die
staatliche Ordnung in Deutschland
ablehnt oder gar beseitigen will der
kann kein Beamter sein meine Damen und
Herren wir sind im Generalbundesanwalt
für sein entschlossenes Vorgehen zu
danken verpflichtet und wir werden den
Weg einer wehrhaften Demokratie
weitergehen für Träume von bewaffnetem
Haus noch in unserer Gesellschaft Platz
vielen Dank
das wurde der Kollege Dr Martin Blum für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir alle Richterinnen und Richter in
unserem Land habe auch ich an meinem
ersten Arbeitstag geschworen mein
amtsgetreu den Grundgesetz auszuüben die
Treue zur Verfassung ist im Richteramt
immanent genauso wie die Beamten und
soldatenverhältnis denn gerade
diejenigen die im Dienst unseres Staates
stehen müssen sich zu unserem Staat
bekennen aktiv für ihn eintreten und
sich von allen Staatsfeinden
distanzieren
diese Verfassungstreue war und ist nicht
nur für mich sondern für fast alle
beamtenrichter und Soldaten in unserem
Land selbstverständlich das zeigt auch
und gerade der Einsatz der vergangenen
Woche und es kann an dieser Stelle nicht
oft genug gesagt werden wir dürfen
dankbar für die Leistung der
Sicherheitsbehörden von Bund und Ländern
sein
[Applaus]
und Frau Kollegin Michalitsch an dieser
Stelle möchte ich schon noch etwas auf
ihre Einlassung sagen wir hätten
tagelang gestiegen das verdreht die
Tatsache ich darf daran erinnern wer die
Sondersitzungen von innen und
Rechtsausschuss beantragt hat die Union
ich darf daran erinnern wer sich dagegen
ausgesprochen hat die Ampel und ich darf
daran erinnern wer bereits am Samstag
diese aktuelle Stunde beantragt hat die
Union der diese Tatsachen hier nicht zu
kennzeichnet sie auf dem Kopf
und die Festnahmen der vergangenen
Wochen zeigen aber leider auch das
Verfassungstreue für einige Beamten
Soldaten und Richter eben nicht
selbstverständlich ist wer hier von
Einzelfällen spricht verkennt die Gefahr
die von diesen Personen für unseren
Staat ausgeht er verkennt dass sich
unser Staat gerade in Zeiten in unserer
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
von Extremisten und Populisten im
Inneren und von Autokraten im äußeren
infrage gestellt und bekämpft wird
uneingeschränkt auf jede und jeden
verlassen muss der in seinem Dienst
steht und für uns als Union ist deshalb
ganz klar klare Kante gegen alle
Staatsfeinde im öffentlichen Dienst
und klare Kante das heißt erstens dass
wir uns bei unseren sicherheits- und
Justizbehörden verbindliche
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen vor der
Einstellung brauchen damit Staatsfeinde
erst gar nicht Staatsdiener werden
zweitens dass wir auch nach der
Einstellung regelmäßige
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen brauchen damit
wir Staatsfeinde im Staatsdienst früher
erkennen drittens dass wir die Regelung
der Union in Baden-Württemberg
disziplinar-maßnahmen durch
Verwaltungsakt statt durch die nachlage
zu ermöglichen ernsthaft prüfen damit
Staatsfeinde er einfacher aus dem
Staatsdienst entfernt werden können und
viertens dass gerade mir Abgeordnete in
Anbetracht des Falls Birgit mal sagt
Winkelmann überlegen müssen ob unser
Schutz vor Strafe und dienstrechtlicher
Verfolgung ein freizeitschein für
Staatsfeinde zurück in den Staatsdienst
sein darf
und wir begrüßen daher das
bundesinnenministerin einige dieser
Vorschläge aufgreifen möchte aber Frau
bundesinnenministerin an dieser Stelle
muss auch eines noch mal klargestellt
werden die Beweislast dafür dass wie sie
es gesagt haben ich anständig bin und
mir nichts habe zu Schulden kommen
lassen trägt in unserem Staat wieder der
Bewerber noch der Beschäftigte in
öffentlichen Dienst denn eine solche
beweislastung der würde alle Bewerber
und Beschäftigten unter einen
Generalverdacht stellen obwohl fast alle
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst auf
dem Boden des Grundgesetzes steht und es
war deshalb auch dringen notwendig dass
sie sich eindeutig von ihren eigenen
Aussagen distanziert haben aber ich
erwarte von einer Bundesministerin und
mal von National von einer
verfassungsministerin die selbst
Juristin ist dass sie sich auch etwas
umgangssprachlich im Fernsehen
ausdrücken kann und ich in kaufe Ihnen
diese Entschuldigung auch nicht ab denn
sie haben hier in diesem Saal am 16 März
2022 auf Frage des Kollegen Herr
Bergmanns erklärt ich zitiere wörtlich
aus dem Plenarprotokoll wir wollen
insbesondere dass die seminarecht und
wahrscheinlich auch das Beamtenrecht
insoweit ändern dass wir beispielsweise
das treibt mich schon seit langem um die
Möglichkeit schaffen die Beweislast
umzukehren war das etwa auch etwas
umgangssprachlich erklärt Professor
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mein
Richter eines für mich nach meiner Wahl
in dieses Haus wichtiger denn je denn
gerade wir als Mitglieder eines
Verfassungsorganen haben uns zu unserem
Staat zu bekennen und unsere Verfassung
aktiv zu verteidigen und ich werde wir
wünschen dass wir das vielleicht in
Zukunft auch wie viele Landtage und
andere Mitglieder der Verfassungsorgane
durch eine entsprechende Verpflichtung
tun Staats- und verfassungsfreiheit
haben auch in diesem Haus keinen Platz
und während diesem Tagen in Zusammenhang
mit der Aufdeckung der Umsturzpläne
rechts terroristischer Reichsbürger von
Inszenierung faselt wir hier über den
Irrglauben der vorläufig festgenommen
inszeniert und wie ihre Pläne als
Rollator Putsch und Fake Staatsrat
absolut der steht nicht auf Seiten
unseres Staates und unserer Verfassung
er steht auf Seiten der Staats- und
Verfassungsfeinde und wer dort steht ist
keine Alternative sondern eine Schande
für Deutschland
Martin Blum war das für die
Unionsfraktion ist hier natürlich darauf
eingegangen dass auch Richter in dieser
Gruppierung dabei waren wie Ärzte
Polizisten Lehrer ehemalige Soldaten und
eben wie auch schon angesprochen eine
ehemalige afd-abgeordnete
elisabeth-kaiser spricht nun für die
Sozialdemokraten Werte Bürgerinnen und
Bürger liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bei den rasieren letzte Woche in 11
Bundesländern durch unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden traten Reichsbürger
Netzwerke Demokratie feindliche
Ideologie und Terrorpläne in einem
Ausmaß zu Tage dass ich wohl die
wenigsten von uns hätten vorstellen
können die aufgedeckten rechts heraus
Strukturen zeigen wie stark sich die
Szene der Reichsbürger Corona
leugnerinnen und Organisatoren der
herbstoffe radikalisiert
es hat sich bestätigt was die SPD immer
schon klar benannt hat und unsere
Innenministerin Nancy Feser sehr
deutlich auch ausgesprochen hat die
größte Bedrohung für unsere Demokratie
in diesem Land ist der Rechtsextremismus
und ich bin froh dass wir endlich eine
Innenministerin haben die diese Gefahr
sehr ernst nimmt und konsequent handelt
es kommt eben entschieden darauf an dass
unsere sicherheitsvermittlungsbehörden
rechtzeitig durchgreifen und wie nun
geschehen Schlimmeres verhindern dieser
Schlag war so erfolgreich weil die
zuständigen Stellen intensiv und gut
koordiniert zusammengearbeitet haben und
für dieses verantwortungsvolle handeln
möchte auch ich in dem
Generalbundesanwalt danken den
Bundeskriminalamt den
Nachrichtendiensten sowie den
Beteiligten Staatsanwaltschaften Polizei
und Verfassungsschutzbehörden in den
Ländern
ebenso auch
für die große Transparenz mit der die
Aufklärer und Ermittlerinnen diese Woche
im Innenausschuss das Parlament über die
Vorgänger informiert haben so schützt
man unsere Demokratie Gesellschaft und
Parlamente liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen schauen wir aber einmal auf die
relativierenden oder auch ausbleibenden
Reaktionen von einigen die bei diesem
Thema vor allen Dingen die
meinungsträgern und auch sonst recht
sehr lautstarken politischen stimmen
wenn man sich das anguckt da muss man
sich doch angesichts der Gefahrenlage
schon recht wundern denn das was wurde
am vergangenen Mittwoch denn
beschlagnahmt mindestens 93 Waffen
darunter 44 potenziell tödliche
Schusswaffen und auch augenscheinlicher
feindeslisten zudem wollte das Netzwerk
offenbar mehrere hundert parameterische
Einrichtungen aufstellen und vor diesem
Hintergrund frage ich mich ernsthaft wie
vernebelt muss man denn sein die
aufgeflogenen Terrorpläne
herunterzuspielen wie es einige
konservative Kreise und natürlich die
AFD hier versuchen oder dass man sich
eben gar nicht zu den größten
bewaffneten rechtsterronetzwerk der
letzten Jahrzehnte äußert wieder
Vorsitzende der Union Friedrich
Schmerzes vorzieht bei der Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Union auch wenn einige
hier nochmal deutlicher geworden sind
ist das doch eine Schieflage ist es doch
eine Schieflage ihrer
sicherheitspolitischen wahrnehmungs
müssen sich dann doch schon den Vorwurf
gefallen lassen wieder einmal rechts
außen nicht ganz genau hinzuschauen denn
so Wahrheit gehört doch aber auch dass
über Jahrzehnte unions besetzte
Innenministerium und auch
Nachrichtendienste nur Halbzeit hat sich
durchgegriffen haben die Frauen normal
dargestellt hat weil wir haben die NSU
terror-serie der Mord an Walter Lübke
und die Attentate von München Halle und
Hanau tragischerweise gezeigt schon eine
Schusswaffe genügt und Tod und Schrecken
zu verbreiten
die Razzien verdeutlichen die richtig es
ist dass unsere bundesinnenministerin
bundesinnenministerin schon weniger
Monate nach Amtsantritt einen
Aktionsplan gegen Rechtsextremismus
aufgesetzt hat hier braucht es
ihr braucht es nun schnelle Konsequenzen
beim Waffenrecht bisher wurden schon
über 1.000 Reichsbürger sind mit Waffen
erzogen aber es ist gut dass das noch
umfassender passieren soll und wir
müssen genauer hinschauen wer eigentlich
welche Waffen bekommen darf außerdem
macht die Verstrickung einiger
Bundeswehr und polizeiangehöriger in das
Terror Netzwerk klar die wichtig ist es
ist das Staatsfeinde konsequent aus den
Sicherheitsbehörden entfernt werden
müssen wer unsere Demokratie verachtet
hat im öffentlichen Dienst nichts
verloren
und den werden wir nun mit der
anstehenden gesetzlichen
ich bin froh dass die Union das immer
anscheinend auch so sieht und es ist an
der Zeit die Rolle der AFD neu zu
bewerten das treibe schuldigte aus ihren
reinkommen das ist kein Zufall sondern
eine direkte Folge der Verachtung für
unsere Demokratie in der AFD als
geistige Brandstifter liefern sie das
ideologische Futter für solche Umsturz
Fantasien und Gewalttaten dr koria
deutlich gemacht
um das Übel dieser Ideologie aber an der
Wurzel zu packen ist umfassende
Prävention immer noch das beste Mittel
gegen Radikalisierung mit dem Ausbau des
Bundesprogramms Demokratie leben zum
Beispiel und den Projekten der
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
gegen Desinformation und
verschwörungserzählungen stärken wir
unsere Gesellschaft gegen rechtsextreme
Ideologie und ich bin sehr froh dass wir
nun das Demokratie fördergesetz auf den
Weg bringen das sind engagierten in
unserem Land dass diese unterstützt die
sich tagtäglich für eine selbstbewusste
und lebendige Demokratie einsetzen und
dass sie von der Union dieses Gesetz in
der letzten Legislaturperiode blockiert
haben und die notwendige Stärkung der
Zivilgesellschaft immer noch in Abrede
stellen ist unverantwortlich deswegen
bin ich froh dass wir das jetzt als
Ampel machen vielen Dank
Elisabeth Kaiser war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und nun spricht Matthias
Helferich einer von sechs
fraktionslosen Abgeordneten hier im
Parlament sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wenn wirklich eine Bedrohung von den
terror-rentlern um den putschprinzen
ausging dann haben die politisch
Verantwortlichen das Leben von 3000
Beamten gefährdet indem sie bereits vor
Wochen genehme medienvertreterin Einsatz
informierten gegen Straftäter die in der
Vergangenheit auch Polizisten ermordeten
muss mit aller Härte vorgegangen werden
doch wissen Sie was mich anwidert es ist
die zur Schau getragene Besorgnis die
die bundesinnenministerin samt ist der
Durchschnitt in jede Kamera des Landes
heuchelt unsere Demokratie ist nicht
gefährdet wenn sie von Spinnern
abgelehnt wird wir haben zu keinem
Zeitpunkt in den Abgrund geschaut Frau
Innenministerin niemand kann die
Demokratie und den Staat die
legitimieren niemand kann das außer
ihnen erst wenn die Bürger das Vertrauen
in den demokratischen rechts und
Verfassungsstaat dann ist unsere
demokratische Ordnung wirklich gefährdet
und dafür dass die Bürger unseres Landes
auf unseren Staat vertrauen können sind
sie als Regierung verantwortlich sie
delegitimieren unseren Staat wenn
türkische Mädchen auf offener Straße von
einem Geisteskranken Afrikaner
abgeschlachtet werden sie delegitimieren
unseren Staat wenn der Onkel des
ermordeten Mädchens in den Medien fragen
muss wie viele Einzelfälle ist denn noch
bedürfe bis man illegale Afrikaner
endlich abschiebe sie legitimieren
unseren Rechtsstaat wenn sich weigern
Frau Innenministerin afghanischen
Gruppen Vergewaltiger einer 14-jährigen
endlich außer Landes zu schaffen Sie die
legitimieren unserer Demokratie wenn Sie
all jene zu Feinden der Demokratie
erklären die lediglich anderer Meinung
sind Edge es aus ihrer Kirchberg hatte
keinen Wassergraben keine
parlamentspolizei keine Spezialkräfte
kein Verfassungsschutz der sie vor ihrem
afrikanischen Mörder Schütze und ihre
Familie vertrauten lediglich auf sie
doch dieses Vertrauen ist zerstört ihre
Aufgabe ist es als Regierung den
anhaltenden Vertrauensverlust nicht
durch aufgeblähte Bedrohungsszenarien
abzumildern ihre Aufgabe ist es aus sich
heraus echtes Vertrauen in unsere
freiheitsordnung und unseren Rechtsstaat
wiederherzustellen und dafür stehe ich
Ihnen gerne zur Verfügung vielen Dank
[Applaus]
der Kollege Dr Konstantin
von 19 stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen Lindholz sie
bringen mich jetzt in die etwas
verrückte Situation dass ich mich für
ein Zitat von Otto schillerechtfertigen
muss aber ich will das gerne tun weil es
hier so oft gefallen ist
sinngemäß gesagt ich kenne diese Gruppe
nicht ich halte sie für ungefährlich ich
selbst sinngemäß ich selbst sammelt
Pilze und ich kann Ihnen sagen alle die
sagen ich kenne diesen Pilz nicht ich
halte ihn für ungefährlich erzählen die
Geschichte häufig nicht zweimal und
deswegen
und deswegen kann ich nur sagen
ein solches Zitat Herr Baumann ein
solches Zitat ist fahrlässig
unvernünftig meinetwegen auch dumm aber
es ist vorsätzlich bösartig ist hier
verkürzt zu zitieren meine Damen und
Herren und es zeigt sie vertuschen dass
sie selbst ein fulminantes
Sicherheitsproblem sind meine Damen und
Herren das verniedlichen von
Rechtsextremisten
[Applaus]
und befeuern von radikal
antidemokratischen oft antisemitischen
narrativen das hat bei Ihnen das hat man
beim Operetten Putsch des Kollegen kurio
gesehen einfach Methode selbst wenn sie
wie jetzt selbst wenn Sie jetzt eine
Ex-Kollegin eine Ex-Kollegin die
Kollegen klar hat gerade gesagt die
jüngsten noch hier im Plenum neben ihnen
gesessen hat und der sie Applaus
gespendet haben wenn diese Kolleginnen
in der letzten Woche in den Knast
einfährt und da heute noch sitzt dann
hört man von ihnen keine
Nachdenklichkeit keine Selbstkritik
sondern immer den gleichen bornierten
geschichtsvergessenen geschmacklosen die
Opfer von rechter Gewalt verhöhnenden
Zionismus meine Damen und Herren
ob Hanau Halle oder auch jetzt Herr
kurio von der AFD immer die gleiche
Leier die Täter sein wohl ein bisschen
verrückt verwirrt senil nicht ganz
richtig im Oberstübchen die
Pathologisierung von
rassistisch und antisemitisch
motivierten Gewalttätern die in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik seit 1945
hunderte von Menschen ermordet haben
weil sie schwarz jüdisch liberal links
türkischstämmig obdachlos Vertreter von
Merkels Flüchtlingspolitik oder was auch
immer waren diese Verharmlosung ist
schlicht unerträglich und dieses Hauses
unwürdig meine Damen und Herren
nun hört man ja das Argument ein
erfolgreicher Staatsstreich habe ja
irgendwie nicht unmittelbar
bevorgestanden häufig haben wir hier
auch gehört aber und Herr Baumann dafür
braucht man
rudimentärste Geschichtskenntnisse man
darf von der Abgründigkeit und der
Abwegigkeit
vieler Ziele von Extremisten eben nicht
auf ihre Harmlosigkeit schließen die
rote armee-fraktion wollte mit ihren
Bomben und mit ihren terrormorden die
arbeitermaßen dazu bringen sich zu
erheben und sich ihrem
anti-imperialistischen Kampf gegen das
System anzuschließen ist das hane
Büchner weltfremder Wahnsinn ja das ist
es allerdings hat das die hat das die
RAF hat sie das ungefährlich gemacht
nein wohl kaum meine Damen und Herren
und deswegen ist das verniedlichen von
schlimmsten Ideologien wie den
reichsbürgern
q-annon und Nationalsozialismus
Anhängern dieses verharmlosen
strukturelle verharmlosen von
Menschenfeindlichkeit es ist Wesens
prägend für ihre politische Organisation
die AFD meine Damen und Herren
was das für die Frage der
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit ihrer Partei
bedeutet müssen andere dafür zuständige
Behörden und unabhängige Gerichte
entscheiden aber eines weiß ich sie sind
ein immanenter Teil dieses akuten
extremistischen Problems dieses Landes
meine Damen und
sie von der AFD sind sich nicht zu
schade all diesen Extremisten ein
politisches Angebot zu machen und ihre
ideologischen Motive zu wiederholen und
zu verstärken wenn man kein kurio genau
zugehört hat hat man es auch gehört es
gibt unzählige Zitate Herr Baumann bei
höcke von Storch Weidel und vielen
vielen anderen Funktionsträgern der AFD
die das abwegige stark antisemitische
narrativ vom großen
Bevölkerungsaustausch antisern
nacherzählen oder bestärken genau diese
abstruse verschwörungsideologie des
Great Reset war in den letzten Jahren
immer wieder der Treibstoff für
zahlreiche schlimmste Mord und Terror
Taten und deswegen ist ihr Mangel an
glaubwürdiger Distanzierung hier eine
Schande für dieses Haus meine Damen und
unsere wehrhafte Demokratie ist
militantenverfassungsfeinden
entschlossen in die Parade gefahren das
ist gut so und dafür bin ich sehr
dankbar es ist ein erster Schritt
herzlichen Dank
für die Liberalen im Deutschen Bundestag
spricht nun Manuel Höferlin er ist
nämlich der innenpolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
wir blicken heute auf Vorkommnisse der
letzten Woche die viele hier in dem
Ausmaße sich nicht haben vorstellen
können die Planung eines Versuches
seines umsturzversuches eines Versuches
die Verfassung die zentralen
demokratischen Werte dieses Landes
anzugreifen
und uns allen muss es seine Warnung sein
mit welcher Akribie diese Pläne im
Detail vorbereitet wurde
da wurden Waffen und Geld besorgt
übrigens nicht nur die 90 Waffen die sie
direkt durch die bei den Besuchen
Durchsuchung gefunden wurden sondern
auch ein weiterer Zugriff auf über 200
Waffen eines legalwaffenhändlers der
Teil des Netzwerkes war da wurden
Unterstützer angeworben
verschwiegenheitserklärungen wurden
unterschrieben bei denen die Straße des
Verrats teilweise mit dem Tod bestraft
wurde wurde die Aufstellung bewaffneter
Einheiten heimatschutzkompanien geplant
Ausrüstung geplant ein
verpflegungskonzept erstellt und
Hierarchien entworfen eine eigene neue
politische Ordnung den Grundfesten das
Reich von 1871 gedanklich aufgebaut und
das alles sollte mit Zielen von Gewalt
durchgesetzt werden und der Tod wurde
absichtlich in Kauf genommen das alle
zeigt warum man das nicht ins
lächerliche ziehen kann und ich bin
entsetzt darüber wie Teile der AFD
diesen Vorgang immer noch auch Sie Herr
Baumann heute morgen im Morgenmagazin
wieder lächerlich gezogen haben
es ist ein gravierender
unter zwischen dem was sie auch gesagt
haben nämlich dass sie einmal Baumann
heute morgen sich auch als
Opfer dargestellte Meinungsfreiheit sei
gefährdet und man sei eingeschüchtert
worden aus ihrer Ecke und es ist ein
Unterschied ob man hier sitzen kann wie
sie und die meinungsfrei äußern kann sie
können hier alles sagen was sie wollen
und Sie können darum kämpfen dass man
ihnen folgt und die Tomate das ist ein
Unterschied ob man das so macht oder die
demokratische Grundordnung mit
Waffengewalt bekämpfen will manchmal
muss man sich fragen sind sie eigentlich
der politische Arm der Reichsbürger oder
sind die Reichsbürger der militärische
Arm der AFD meine Damen und Herren
sie mit ihrer Meinungsfreiheit müssen
wir aushalten die die mit Gewalt
vorgehen die sind eine Sache für den
Staatsanwaltschaft und das ist der
Unterschied sie müssen wir erdulden das
andere werden wir nicht ertragen
ja es gibt ein Unterschied zwischen dem
was in dem Gedanken dieser
Reichsbürger und
Verschwörungstheoretiker die sich
zusammengetan haben mit wollen und
können vielleicht möglich war nicht
alles was die gedacht haben kann man mit
den Mitteln anstreben aber der
Justizminister hat gesagt das ist nicht
das Entscheidende sondern eine
terroristische Vereinigung mit dem Code
in Kauf zu nehmen das ist die Anklage
und ich glaube diese besondere
gefährliche Gefahr ist nicht das was
dort gedacht wird und was gesagt wird
denn wir haben Meinungsfreiheit aber
die Mischung die toxische Mischung
dieser Ideologien gepaart mit
militärischen Fähigkeiten von mindestens
acht Personen in diesem Netzwerk mit
Personen die Spezialkenntnisse aus dem
militärischen und polizeilichen Bereich
haben mit Zugriff auf über 200 Waffen
mit Insiderwissen einer ehemaligen
afd-abgeordneten der Strukturen und der
Räumlichkeiten hier mit Planungen in der
Detailtiefe das ist das brandgefährliche
dieses Vorgangs und deswegen bin ich
sehr glücklich dass die Behörden im
richtigen Moment zugegriffen haben und
dieses diese Truppe hochgenommen haben
trotz des Erfolgs müssen wir uns sagen
die Gefahr durch Reichsbürger ist damit
nicht gebannt wir müssen uns auch
intensiver als bisher die Frage stellen
wie gehen wir eigentlich mit Menschen
die in diesen Bereich driften um denn es
handelt sich eben nicht um breitbeinige
Spinnereien am Stammtisch es hat sich
gezeigt dass die Verachtung für die
demokratische Grundordnung die vom
Parlament hier auch immer wieder
befeuert wird aus der rechten Ecke auch
in vielen Teilen der Menschen im draußen
dieses außerhalb dieses Gebäudes
weitergetragen werden und die Feinde
dieser Gesellschaft finden wir nicht
mehr nur noch an den Rändern sie finden
Sie unter Richtern unter Beamten unter
Soldaten unter Köchen unter Menschen die
also selbst
in unserem Staat leben und ein Eid auf
ihn geleistet haben und ich befürchte
dass wenn diese Reichsbürger dort so
agieren und hier im Parlament setzen
dass wir viel stärker als bisher diese
Menschen abholen müssen ich bin nicht
bereit
dass Menschen die diese Verschwörung
Ideologien über sich ertragen verloren
gegangen werden an die politische Rechte
wir müssen darum kämpfen dass Menschen
in Deutschland diesen Staat schätzen
diese demokratische Grundordnung
schätzen sie verteidigen und sie nicht
mit Gewalt angreifen wollen das ist das
was wir mit Entschlossenheit
vorantreiben wollen und das ist das was
die Koalition auch in Zukunft machen
wird
Manuel Höferlin war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und damit kommen wir schon
zum vorletzten Redner in dieser
aktuellen Stunde das ist Michael
Breilmann er sitzt für die
Unionsfraktion im Ausschuss für Inneres
und Heimat sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist heute viel gesprochen
worden von werfter Demokratie und es ist
heute oft erwähnt worden dass die
demokratischen Parteien zusammenstehen
müssen
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich kann
mich nur wundern und es ist auch
wirklich ärgerlich und auch nicht gut
für unsere Demokratie wenn ich die Rede
der Kollegin Kaiser höre und auch
Vorrednerinnen und Vorredner die der
Unionsfraktion vorwerfen sie hätten zu
wenig gegen Extremismus getan ich kann
ihn nur eins sagen es war die
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung die ein
kabinettsausschuss gebildet hat die 89
Einzelmaßnahmen konkrete mit auf den Weg
gebracht hat und mehr als eine Milliarde
Euro von den Jahren 2021 bis 2024 zur
Verfügung gestellt hat gegen den Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus ganz konkret wir
haben uns von ihnen nichts zu belehren
und wenn wir von wehrhafter Demokratie
sprechen dann sage ich auch dann gehört
dazu eine Regierung die einig ist bei
den richtigen Fragen und bei den
Lösungen wir haben viel von der
Ministerin heute zum Waffenrecht gehört
das sind aber allgemeine Ankündigungen
nichts Konkretes der
Bundesjustizminister von der FDP
schweigt sich aus und die FDP-Fraktion
lässt über ein Fraktionsvize vermählen
dass man eine generale generelle
Verschärfung des Waffenrechts ablehnt
und sie wollen uns kritisieren dass wir
zu still und so ruhig werden das kann
doch wohl nicht wahr sein
und es ist auch viel zu AFD gesagt
worden ich kann nur sagen die
Debattenbeiträge aber auch die
Zwischenrufe der afd-fraktion zeigen
eigentlich dass sie bei der AFD dass sie
völlig zurecht als Verdachtsfall des
Verfassungsschutzes eingestuft werden
und ich finde es ist jetzt auch richtig
und wichtig dass ihre Rolle die Rolle
der afd-fraktion als AFD als
Sammelbecken für radikalisierende
Gruppen jetzt auch weiter Stück für
Stück offengelegt denn es gibt keine
Gründe zur Verharmlosung der
reichsbürgerszene nein die Beschuldigten
besaßen weitgehende Pläne scharfe Waffen
und nicht unerhebliche gelten und da ist
die Lage zwar beherrschbar aber
definitiv nicht harmlos das muss man
ernst nehmen diese Person die
Festgenommenen hätten definitiv Schaden
anrichten können und die Szene wird ja
weiter bei unzählige telegram-kanäle um
sympatisieren denken wir nur das ist
auch gerade angeklungen an die
Todesfälle und Verletzung bei
Polizeibeamtinnen und Beamten bei
vorherigen Aktionen gehen
da an dieser Stelle nochmal herzlichen
Dank an alle Einsatzkräfte und
Sicherheitsbehörden für ihren
geleisteten Dienst ich möchte aber
einen weiteren dank anschließen möchte
mich euren Namen meiner Fraktion bei
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars bedanken und
es ist schon erstaunlich und es wird ja
auch vorhin schon angesprochen dass die
wichtigen und wirklich sehr
zielführenden Sondersitzung des Rechts
und Innenausschusses nur gegen den
Willen der ampelkoalitionäre zustande
kam und als Begründung kam sie bei der
Koalition vor den Behörden solle
genügend Zeit gegeben werden um den
Sachverhalt aufzuarbeiten es ist heute
noch mal klar geworden und sie haben es
ja auch selber eingestanden das war ein
sehr sehr schwaches Argument
ich muss nach der Sitzung am Montag
sagen ich bin in dieser
Legislaturperiode noch nie so umfassend
noch nie so umfassend auch zeitlich in
einem Gremium von BKA
generalbundesanfall und Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz informiert worden das
hat Maßstäbe gesetzt und es bleibt auch
hoffentlich so aber es war richtig und
deswegen sieht es ja auch zeigt man ja
auch noch mal dass wir handlungsfähig
waren und gehandelt haben es war richtig
so dass wir diese Sondersituation
beantragt haben
und deutlich geworden in dieser
Sondersitzung ist im übrigen auch
adressiert an die Linke die Reichsbürger
selbstverwalterszene das ist schon eine
sehr sehr eigene ganz besondere Mischung
von Personen die gefährlich ist seine
Mischung von ganz verschiedenen
Charakteren
Verschwörungstheoretikern für einen
Gläubigen Querdenkern auch aus der Mitte
der Gesellschaft und die
Sicherheitsbehörden schätzen das von den
22 bis 23.000 Personen im szenebereich
ca 5% klassische rechtsextreme sind und
deswegen sollten wir nicht so tun als
wenn das alles rechtsextreme sind und
wir pauschal das Etikett
Rechtsextremismus an die
reichsbürgerszene setzen das wäre fatal
wir brauchen einen 360 Grad
und eines möchte ich auch noch mal zum
Schluss sagen unsere Demokratie ist
Werft Demokratie lebt wenn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für sie eintreten
und starke Stimmen sie verteidigen
deswegen sollten alle gemeinsam als
Demokraten Handeln herzlichen Dank für
Ihre aufmerksam
so weit Michael Breilmann und Dirk Wiese
wird hier diese aktuelle Stunde beenden
erst der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
vergangenen Woche hat dieser Staat
gezeigt hat diese Demokratie dieser
Rechtsstaat deutlich gemacht dass diese
Demokratie gegen die Feinde dieser
Republik gegen die Feinde einer
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
gegen die die eine an ein anderes
Deutschland wollen eine andere
Grundordnung wollen wehrhaft ist und ich
bin allen und das ist oft gesagt worden
heute hier in dieser Debatte allen die
da in der letzten Woche zu beigetragen
haben insbesondere denjenigen aus den
Sicherheitsdiensten denjenigen aus der
Polizei dankbar dass das aufgedeckt
worden ist und das was sie vorhanden
verhindert worden ist und da gehört
allen unseren Dank
Helmut Schmidt hat einmal gesagt mir
liegt eine doppelte Einsicht am erstens
dass unsere offene Gesellschaft und
Demokratie mit vielen Unvollkommenheiten
behaftet ist und auch Politiker nicht
frei von menschlichen Schwächen sind und
es wäre auch ein Irrtum unsere
Demokratie zu einem Ideal zu erheben in
dem alles komplett funktionieren würde
nein das ist das auch nicht aber er hat
zweitens gesagt und das ist entscheidend
gleichwohl haben wir Deutschen unserer
katastrophalen Geschichte legen allen
Grund mit Zähigkeit an dieser Demokratie
festzuhalten sie immer wieder zu
erneuern und immer wieder ihren Feinden
tapfer entgegenzutreten und da sind wir
alle gefordert das gemeinsam zu machen
das sind wir alle in diesem Land
gefordert und ich will das ganz deutlich
sagen weil Herr Baumann an der einen
oder anderen Stelle gerade Zitate von
Otto Schilling nicht ganz lesen kann
Herr Baumann ich will ihn mal eins sagen
die SPD wird im kommenden Jahr 160 Jahre
alt und seit 160 Jahren wissen wir dass
der Feind dieser Republik rechts steht
und wenn OT Familie heute zugehört hat
in dieser Debatte und vielleicht im
hohen Alter heute zugehört hat ich kann
Ihnen sagen das was sie hier reingerufen
haben er würde seinen Helm und seinen
Knüppel wieder rausholen er weiß wo der
Feind dieser Republik steht
und Liebe Uni Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Union lassen Sie mich auf ein zwei
Punkte auch noch mal eingehen erstens am
vergangenen Mittwoch gab es eine
Unterrichtung aller Fraktion auch ihrer
und ich bin Ihnen auch durchaus dankbar
dass sie das gerade mit der
Sondersitzung noch mal hervorgehoben
haben und auch erwähnt haben denn und
das hat man ja auch gemerkt in den
letzten 48 Stunden viele von ihnen in
der Unionsfraktion haben durch diese
Sondersitzungen glaube ich erstmal
gemerkt was da letzte Woche vorgefallen
ist das will ich noch mal eindeutig
unterstreichen das ein
Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU der Ende
2021 in der Süddeutschen Zeitung gesagt
hat bei der Abgrenzung nach rechts sind
wir Konsequenz dass man in so einer
Situation fünf Tage lang schweigt das
geht nicht das halte ich für ein
Uniklinik
und jetzt will ich auch noch mal ganz
kurz auf Herrn Breilmann eingehen Herr
Breilmann sie haben gerade einige Punkte
auf Zuruf hier versucht klarzustellen
weil sie sind erst Mitglied des
Deutschen Bundestages seit Oktober 2021
und ich war in der letzten
Legislaturperiode in vielen Gesprächen
mit dem Bundesinnenministerium dabei in
vielen Gesprächen letztendlich mit den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ihrer Fraktion
dabei und ich muss das noch mal deutlich
unterstreichen am Ende der letzten
Legislaturperiode als wir den
Maßnahmenplan Rechtsextremismus in
Teilen umsetzen wollen als wir das
Demokratie fördergesetz einführen sollen
sollten da hätte Horst Seehofer lieber
auf dieser Seite des Hauses gesessen und
hat sich in Teilen für ihre Fraktion
geschämt weil sie nicht mitgemacht haben
diese Dinge umzusetzen und das gehört
heute zur Ehrlichkeit mit dazu
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrter Herr Innenminister Beuth
ich bin dankbar dass sie heute auch hier
in dieser Debatte das Wort ergriffen
haben und auch noch mal einiges sehr
deutlich gemacht haben im gemeinsamen
Kampf den wir gegenüberstehen ich glaube
aber und ein bisschen selbstkritik ist
angebracht Hessen ist jetzt nicht das
Beispiel und gerade das hessische
Innenministerium das in vergangenen
Jahren durch Transparenz und Aufklärung
im Kampf gegen Rechts die Vorreiterrolle
eingenommen hat ich glaube da ist
einiges zu tun bei Ihnen und wenn Sie
heute hier das Versprechen abgeben das
ist besser wird das besser ausgeführt
wird dann ist das glaube ich ein
Erkenntnisgewinn an sich schon von daher
ist jetzt die entscheidende Frage was
wir tun wollen und was wir tun müssen
wir müssen sicherlich das
Sicherheitskonzept hier im Bundestag uns
noch mal sehr genau anschauen wir wollen
dass Demokratie fördergesetz was heute
auf den Weg gebracht worden ist
wirklich verabschieden wir wollen
gleichzeitig beim Disziplinarrecht sehr
genau hinschreiben schauen
Verfassungsfeinde müssen leichter aus
dem öffentlichen Dienst entfernt werden
und das auch durch Verwaltungsakt aber
ich sage auch ganz Deutschland deutlich
wir wollen auch beim Waffenrecht
hinschauen da wo Lücken sind wollen wir
diese schließen und das ist richtig und
das müssen wir auch gemeinsam angehen
und zu guter Letzt lassen Sie mich
Einsatz sagen weil ich doch ziemlich
schockiert war über die Rede des
Kollegen Helferich ich muss schon sagen
die deutsche Rechte im Jahr 2022 ist
eine bizarre Kreuzung von Stahlhelm und
aluhut das was sie hier geredet haben
ist dieses Hauses unwürdig sie sind aus
ihrer eigenen Fraktion ausgeschlossen
worden und das schlimme ist sie haben
alle applaudiert und das ist macht einen
fassungslos
[Applaus]
Wiese war das und das war dann auch die
Aktuelle Stunde zur Bedrohung durch
Netzwerke von reichsbürgern und
Rechtsextremisten und es wird dieses
Thema aber natürlich noch weiter
beschäftigen und ähm auch die
angesprochenen Themen eben weil das
Waffenrecht oder auch das
Disziplinarrecht verändert werden soll
und bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
jetzt zum Beispiel beim Waffenrecht
schon angekündigt hat das noch in diesem
Jahr ist einen ersten Entwurf geben soll
aus ihrem Ministerium
der nächste Tag ist ordnungspunkt
beschäftigt sich mit
Moldau die
Fraktionen von SPD grün und FDP haben
einen Antrag eingereicht indem sie
fordern den EU-Beitrittskandidaten
Moldau weiter zu unterstützen und so
fordern sie eben die Bundesregierung auf
diese diesen Kandidaten zu unterstützen
im Juni haben die EU-Staaten nach einer
Empfehlung der Kommission die Ukraine
und aber eben auch Moldau offiziell zu
Beitrittskandidaten erklärt
und nun möchten die Fraktion dass sich
die Bundesregierung eben dafür einsetzt
aber z.B auch den Beitrittsprozess
modernisiert in denen etwas
Zwischenschritte eingeführt werden und
die erste Rednerin zu diesem Thema ist
Merle Spellerberg für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Entschuldigung
doppelte besser so sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen als wir
das letzte Mal hier im Plenum über
Moldau gesprochen haben war april die
Premierministerin Natalia gabrielitza
war zu Besuch hier im Bundestag und hat
uns von den Ängsten und Bedürfnissen der
Menschen in ihrem Land berichtet und
schon damals tobte der brutale
Angriffskrieg auf die benachbarte
Ukraine es waren schon da tausende
Menschen aus der Ukraine angekommen und
wurden in Moldau aufgenommen und
versorgt der Druck auf die demokratische
die Pro europäische Regierung wuchs
schon damals auf Betreiben Russlands
enorm an Moldau das ärmste Land Europas
hatte schon damals zu kämpfen und hat
gekämpft und tut dies immer noch und wir
stehen dabei an Mäuse
gemeinsam mit unseren internationalen
Partnern haben wir schon im Frühjahr
mehr als 650 Millionen Euro
bereitgestellt aber das war im Frühling
liebe Kolleginnen jetzt ist Winter und
in Chisinau ist es bitterkalt im
November wurden Gasimporte aus Russland
halbiert der gesamte Strom aus dem
russisch gestützten transistrieren wurde
komplett gestoppt ganze 70 Prozent der
landesweiten Versorgung Familien
bezahlen bis zu drei Viertel ihres
Einkommens für Ihre Energiekosten
Straßenlampen müssen ausgestellt werden
Lebensmittelpreise steigen die Inflation
Inflation steht bei 34%
und die russische Einflussnahme liebe
Kolleginnen hinter all diesen
Entwicklungen ist nicht versteckt
sondern ziemlich offensichtlich was wir
hier sehen ist Erpressung Erpressung auf
dem Rücken der Menschen dem Rücken der
armen Menschen und den Schaden den die
Menschen davontragen bietet Nährboden
Nährboden für die Pro russische
Opposition die schon seit Amtsantritt
versucht die Regierung und Maja Sendung
zu destabilisieren in Moldau versucht
Russland einen weiteren krisenherz in
Europa zu schaffen und unsere
Solidarität zu testen
meldau ist heute geschwächt und wird
gerade vor unseren Augen Opfern des
russischen energiekrieges aber was sich
geändert hat liebe Kolleginnen was sich
seit dem Frühjahr geändert hat ist das
Moldau heute offiziell
Beitrittskandidaten der EU ist das ist
gut für Moldau und das ist gut für
Europa
und es gibt uns einen Momentum unsere
außenpolitischen Bemühungen mit Moldau
weiter auszubauen wir unterstützen die
Menschen in Moldau wir unterstützen die
Menschen in Moldau und ihrem Wunsch nach
mehr Demokratie Bekämpfung der
Oligarchen mehr Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
ein Ende der Korruption wir zeigen mehr
europäische Solidarität gegen russische
Erpressung und das machen wir auch mit
finanzieller Unterstützung Ende November
und Svenja Schulze bei der bereits
weitere Gelder für die Unterstützung
die internationale Konferenz gibt nun
mehr als 1,5 Milliarden Euro damit
sollen unter anderem Energieeffizienz
und erneuerbare Energien gestärkt werden
denn in Moldau sehen wir ganz akut das
Energiesicherheit eine Kernfrage von
einem integrierten Sicherheitsbegriff
ist
und auch die anhaltende Hilfe die Moldau
für die geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
leistet soll weiterhin gestützt werden
kurzfristig in zentralen
Krisenmanagement und langfristig in der
Integration der Menschen die in Moldau
bleiben werden
wie wir nun weitermachen sollten ist für
mich ganz klar wir unterstützen molders
Resilienz und stärken den Weg aus der
russischen Energieabhängigkeit und
überall dort liebe Kolleginnen wo wir
unsere Partnerinnen vor Putin schützen
können leisten wir einen Beitrag zu
Sicherheit wir tun dies für die Menschen
in Moldau aber auch aus ureigenem
Interesse denn putinskrieg richtet sich
eben nicht nur gegen die Ukraine die
Aggressionen nicht nur gegen Moldau
sondern gegen Demokratie
bei den notwendigen Schritten für einen
schnellen EU-Beitritt stehen wir an
Molde aus Seite in den aktuellen Krisen
begleiten wir weiterhin Justiz und
Verwaltungsreform wir unterstützen den
Kampf gegen Menschenrechtsverstöße wie
Diskriminierung von Roma oder Gewalt
gegen Frauen oder die lgbtqi-community
wir setzen uns ebenso für eine bessere
Anmeldung Anbindung moldaus an die EU
ein überschienen infraktur Schienen
Infrastruktur ebenso wie über Klima und
energiepolitische Kooperation deshalb
liebe Kolleginnen bitte ich um die
Unterstützung unseres Antrags um all
diese Bemühungen aufrecht zu erhalten
und weiter zu stärken
vielen Dank auf der Tribüne hat der
Botschafter der Republik Moldau Platz
genommen eure Exzellenz ich begrüße Sie
herzlich im Namen des gesamten Hauses es
ist schön dass sie der Debatte hier
frei wohnen und ich will Ihnen für den
Deutschen Bundestag versichern dass wir
die Situation in ihrem Land sehr gut
kennen genau anschauen und mit dieser
Debatte auch deutlich machen wollen dass
unsere Herzen soll unsere Solidarität
bei ihnen sind herzlichen Dank der
Kollege Knut abraham hat das Wort für
die cdu/csu
und Knut Abraham sitzt im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es fällt einem doch wirklich
schwer hier im warmen Herzen Berlins in
diesem gut geheizten Plenarsaal sich
vorzustellen wie dramatisch die Lage in
der Republik Moldau ist und Merle
schwellenberg hat ja gerade schon darauf
hingewiesen auf die Stromausfälle die es
gibt das Land ist schwer getroffen von
dem Krieg direkte Folge der
raketeneinschläge in der Ukraine die
Stromausfälle die Sicherheitslage die
externe Sicherheitslage russische
Desinformation und Subvention
Wirtschaftseinbruch wir haben es gehört
die Inflation mehr als 30 %. unter all
diesen Problemen ist aber ganz sicher
die Energiekrise die schwierigste die
Menschen in moldauzahlen Energiepreise
so hoch wie unsere hier in Deutschland
aber mit Durchschnittseinkommen von 400
bis 500 Euro die Regierung versucht
alles um die Menschen entlasten aber es
fehlen schlicht die finanziellen Mittel
warum ist es jetzt so wichtig Moldau zu
unterstützen es geht um noch mehr denn
die proeuropäische Regierung unter
Präsidentin Meier sandou
arbeitet entschlossen leistet enormes
enormes das Land wirklich zu reformieren
und in die Europäische Union zu führen
das sind richtig gute Leute die unsere
Unterstützung brauchen
die Verleihung des
EU-Kandidatenstatus war eine epochale
Entscheidung jetzt geht es dieses
Momentum zu erhalten wichtige
Zwischenschritte zu gehen etwa der
Zulassung in den EU Binnenmarkt trifft
Weise es darf auf jeden Fall eines nicht
geben eine zweite Hängepartie wie wir
sie im westlichen Balkan leider haben
sehen müssen
seien wir auch stand wenn die Regierung
es nicht schafft die Menschen
mitzunehmen und sie scheitert würden die
Folgen für alle in Europa schlimmen denn
wir wollen uns nicht vorstellen was eine
pro russische Regierung in einem Land
nur 50 km von Odessa entfernt um mit
russischen Soldaten auf dem Staatsgebiet
nämlich in transistrien für die
Sicherheit der Ukraine und der ganzen EU
bedeuten würde in dieser schwierigen
Situation schaut Moldau auf uns eine
ganz wichtige Rolle dabei spielen
übrigens zur Stabilisierung der
moldauischen Demokratie unsere
politischen Stiftung die Adenauer
Stiftung z.B hat im heute auch schon
Staatsfernsehen etabliert eine Talkshow
in der regelmäßig auf Russisch russische
Desinformation demontiert wird das finde
ich eine ganz großartige Sache und das
sollten wir mit noch mehr
Unterstützung leisten und
unterstützen wie gesagt so der
vorliegende Antrag beinhaltet viele gute
Ideen irgendwie erinnert mich das ganze
aber an April Frau schwellerberg da
haben wir nämlich unseren Antrag
besprochen und wir hätten das alles also
viel viel früher haben können nämlich am
6 April und auch ein bisschen besser und
noch ein bisschen präziser denn
bitte darf nicht nur angekündigt werden
sie muss auch bei den Menschen ankommen
die solidaritätsplattform für Moldau
Frau Ministerin einen wirklich sehr sehr
gute Sache hat wir haben schon gehört
659 Millionen Euro zugesagt allerdings
und das ist ein Problem gibt es kein
Forum keine Plattform die wirklich
kontrolliert ob diese Gelder auch
tatsächlich ankommen die moldauerische
Regierung jedenfalls hat äußerste
Schwierigkeiten das zu übersehen und
sind denn die im April
zugesagten 50 Millionen Euro aus der
Bundes aus der Bundesrepublik wirklich
angekommen dort auf jeden Fall müssen
wir aufhören mit Zahlen Verwirrung zur
stiften es in Antrag ist es auch so 615
werden noch zusätzlich genannt dem ist
nicht so ganz klar ist die Hilfe muss
jetzt kommen der Winter ist da und diese
Antrag ist okay und er verdient hier
unsere Unterstützung vielen Dank
Knut abraham war das hat diesen Antrag
geadelt kann man sagen mit der
Bezeichnung er sei ganz okay wir
verlassen den Bundestag für heute morgen
sind wir natürlich im gewünschte
gewohnter Manier wieder ab 8:45 Uhr für
Sie da und starten mit einem Interview
zur
energiepreisbremse mit Gesine wird von
den Linken und Lukas Köhler von der
FDP-Fraktion jetzt geht es hier weiter
mit den Kollegen aus Bonn und namentlich
mit Maja Weber